Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
So I'm a little late.
I had a little bit of a mini panic attack.
So for those who were not reading pre-chat, today I got a
text from my landlord and they're like, Hey, Doki.
The strata of the building wants to do a warranty review of
the building and ask residents to complete a questionnaire
about possible deficiencies.
so I'll need a minute to check the status of your unit.
Can you please let me know when I can come to do this?
That's to be done before May 19th.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
That's all right.
I was like, I have nothing wrong with my apartment at the
moment.
And I was like, all right, let me, I'm going to take a nap
and then text him right back today after I woke up.
But walked dead.
I had to use the bathroom.
I had to pee.
And I was like, nothing's broken.
Everything seems fine in my apartment right now.
I'll be okay with him coming up anytime soon.
Maybe like this week or something.
Get it done and over with.
Thank God I didn't text him back right away.
I was thinking about texting him after the stream.
Thank God I decided that.
Anyway, I decided to pee.
I was like thinking I was like oh no uh my toilet I ran out
of toilet paper let me go grab the toilet paper at the
cupboard anyway so um at the the bathroom cupboard so I was
just like all right let me just lean over because the toilet
paper is right there I don't want to you know just finish
peeing I don't want to get up and just do a little piece to
me over there let me just lean over and grab Surely nothing
could go wrong, right?
Surely.
In my head, I thought, oh, that's...
In my head, I thought, this will be fine.
And, well, I played some silly games, and I found out...
I...
I played some really silly games, and I found out...
that it was indeed not fine.
I rolled the die and I lost the gavel.
I played a silly game and won a silly prize.
So, yeah, so I was just like, oh oh i have to get this fixed
before he comes up here i so i maybe i was maybe i should
have done the piece of me over to the cupboard and got the
toilet paper instead of trying to lean on it lean on it a
little uh so basically all right i'll give you guys a
visualization of what happened so the cupboard is next to
the toilet and then when you're sitting on the toilet all
right let me do like a little picture here let me i was just
like well all right so here's my little picture and then
there's the cupboard with the toilet paper so i don't know
if you guys can visualize this very well uh and then here's
the toilet paper the squares are the toilet paper like dokey
you can't see just just give me a second i'm i'm sniffing it
right now so uh let's see let me i snipped it so here's the
visualization so as me on the toilet there's the cupboard so
i'm right next to the cupboard in my head i was like let me
just lean on it a little bit and then just grab the toilet
paper over and usually okay so this is what i you know i
this was like time where i was decided not to be lazy where
i put my toilet paper in the cupboard and so uh in the past
you know i never had to lean over the grab something and i
would just put like you know because i live by myself i was
like who's gonna fucking know like who's gonna care it's
just me i live by myself and in the past what i would do is
I just put, every time I ran out of toilet paper, I buy
like, you know, you know, I buy toilet paper, and it's like
a bag of toilet paper, and then I just put it in front of
the toilet.
So like, if I ever run out, I can just grab it in the bag of
toilet paper, and then put it beside me.
Because I was like, who's gonna know?
It's like, I'm, who am I like trying to like do this for?
You know?
Like,
Who am I doing this for?
Anyway, like, it's just me on the toilet.
And I'm trying to be efficient here.
And then, so, like, no one's gonna see this but me.
Like, like, why do I need to, like, put it away?
Anyway, so, when I got back from LA, I was like, you know
what, I ran out of toilet paper.
And so I had to, you know, I gotta buy new toy, more toilet
paper.
So I went and grabbed more toilet paper.
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna change my life forever.
I'm gonna be less lazy.
And I get punished for it.
Look at this is my lesson to me to continue to be lazy.
Okay.
So I was like, I'm gonna be less lazy.
I'm gonna put my toilet paper away in the cupboard.
So I don't just have it like just lying there on the
bathroom floor.
So at least it'll look nicer.
So.
I'm just thinking like you know so at least it looks nicer
and looks like I got my life together you know and now
that's why I was like I'm gonna put it all in the cupboard
and then whenever I run out I'll just grab some more in the
cupboard and now look what happened look what that got me
now I have a fucking broken cupboard look at that I have a
broken cupboard because I put it away in the fucking
cupboard.
I should just left it on the bathroom floor in front of me
as it should be.
So when I run out, I can just grab it in front of me instead
of fucking trying to lean over and grab it right on in the
cupboard.
At least it's not on the floor anymore.
Anyway.
out how to fix this or call someone to fix this uh before
before my landlord finds out we're in sees all of this uh g
thank you let's reach out thank you thank you the moral of
this story always choose laziness it's just efficient who
the knows anyway it's just me and my own bathroom it's like
i don't care i don't even know who i was trying to prove i
don't know who i was like do this for it it was for me but
clearly i wasn't happy about it clearly it wasn't for me
um but yeah i'm gonna remember next time to just leave it on
the floor in front and leave it on the bathroom floor uh and
seven thank you super chat thank you thank you this that is
an easy fix dokey take some toothpicks and jam them in the
hole break them off flush with the surface and uh screw it
back in i did not understand 80 of that instructions but i i
think i'll figure it out i think i'm gonna figure it out
thank you this super chat um and seven thank you thank you
um but yeah anyway so yes that's why i was late i
accidentally did that and i was like having a mini panic
attack because i was just like oh my what the do i do i'm
just glad i did not i'm glad i did not text my landlord back
instantly about like a day to come check the apartment so i
can i got some time i got at least a like a week and a half
to figure figure this out uh i got a week and a half um what
was the lesson i learned today don't change who you are if
it works it works you don't have to prove this to any don't
have to prove this to anyone if it works it works just keep
the way they keep how it was keep the things as it was
that's rod no it's okay he has to have he has to have my
permission to come up it's like landlord tenant rules thank
god do the peace shuffle i should have done the peace
shuffle yeah if it ain't broke don't it that's what is that
the thing if it ain't broke is that the famous thing don't
fix it yeah if it ain't broke don't fix it uh another okay
okay other than that other than me accidentally breaking my
covered uh uh dad has also got lazier not just me uh because
today uh you know how like usually like like a normal dog uh
i said Thank you.
Thank you.
This accent sounds like something Joker would do.
Make sure to check your house with suspicious clouds.
I have to know because I am Batman, not Bruce Wayne.
Thank you.
So, um, dad has also gotten lazier.
So, you know how like a normal dog, uh, when they hear
something outside, they will, uh, run up to the door and
then just start barking at the door, you know, just because
they're like, who is that, you know?
Um, so dad has stopped doing that.
Oh, he still barks.
barks but he stopped doing the the other steps where he
would go to the door and bark at the door instead he stays
in the comfy ass in my comfy ass bed see they all cuddle up
he hears a sound and just barks from the bed which by the
way my bed is like the furthest from the door too um he's
just like who is that tell him to get out of here But I'm
gonna, but like I'll tell him from here.
Look at him.
I like went over.
I was like, what the fuck is he barking?
I was like, why are you barking so far away?
Like, and then I come over and I see this.
I see him all cuddled up in the bed and he's just like, oh,
like tell him to gleam.
You think I didn't hear you from this comfy ass bed?
so cozy
yeah and he's just like tell that man to leave this is my
house anyway this is a comfy ass bed i'm not leaving this
bed i'm like dad if you're gonna try if you're trying to
keep your turf you're not doing it you have to get out of
the bed first like what the is it what the fuck are you
gonna do in that bed if someone breaks in uh he doesn't look
like he's he's i'm wearing a dog shirt underneath don't
worry don't worry he's definitely wearing a dog shirt
underneath the blanket um i wouldn't want to stand he's too
comfy he didn't want to leave
so um so yeah my dog has also gone lazier he has stopped a
pre-has-stop like like moving from if he hears a sound he
would say where he is and would just bark from where he is
and he's just like that's right you heard me i don't need to
walk up to the door to show prove anything i could do it
right here in my cozy blanket he's like you're a froth froth
so yeah that's my dad
also when i was walking dad yesterday i bumped into this
lady like oh my it felt like she was like at the med gala
like she was heading to the med gala or something but i
bumped into this lady she was like dressed head to toe toe
with like designers oh like with designer like louis vuitton
gucci like everything on her was just designer uh uh
designer wear the designer fashion and she's like oh hello
darling like she that's how she was saying stalking she was
like hello darling Your dog is so cute, sweetie.
And I'm like, oh my God, are you real?
Oh my God, it feels like it felt like she just came out of
from like Devil Wars Prada or something.
Yeah, she actually said, darling and everything.
And then dad was looking at it and was like, oh my God, what
are you?
I'm never seeing you.
Like, what are you?
And she's like, oh, darling, your dog is so cute.
And I'm like, oh, thank you.
I was like, oh my God.
oh my i've never seen like a real like i thought it was like
people i didn't realize they were real people i thought it
was just like i thought it was like a movie stereotype yeah
corral de ville type shit i thought it was just like a movie
trope or something but i was like oh my god there's people
like this in real life and she lives in my pot it was it was
apartment complex yeah i thought it was like a tv slash
movie trope and i was like oh my god wait she's real um so i
was just like stunned i was like oh my god i get i can't
believe i get to witness like i can't believe i get to see
this in real life uh i didn't watch devilworth's prada too i
was just i saw it everywhere though on like twitter and
everything um yeah she was corolla all his corolla and
witness protection yeah she's in witness protection right
now living in canada uh she's she might have like she came
from down like i you know i clicked down and then she was
still in the elevator so she was definitely on the floor
higher than mine um anyway guys today we are going to play
vampire crawlers it's from the creators of vampire survivors
i have never played uh a card building but i will say card
jitsu does not count uh it's like baby's first card game um
Anyway, so I've never actually played a card battler deck
building game before.
So this is going to be my first time.
I saw a lot.
I've been looking for trying it out.
Even though I've never played these types of games before.
I was looking forward to trying this out.
Because I saw a lot of really good reviews.
I never even played Slay.
I know a lot of people are like, oh, you should try Slay the
Spire and stuff.
But I'm a little bit intimidated to play Slay the Spire.
Just because like I never had never played these types of
genres before so this won't be my first time I decided to
start with vampire crawlers Only because it seems easier and
also I like vampire survivors So I trust the devs and what
they do and it has a lot of good reviews and too so you know
You know I've always I wanted to try out because of that the
dev seems to know what they're doing and I the devs.
Let me see.
Alright, I just need the game to show up.
Hello, game.
Show up on my screen.
Oh, wait.
I gotta get rid of the switch.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we go up to it.
We go in.
Knife.
Ooh.
Thank god I only have one card.
Oh, now there's three bats?
Don't worry, my trusty knives got it.
Oh, I have the King Bible.
Oh, I know what that is.
I played Vampire Survivor.
I got Pancake.
I can use WASD.
Okay, that's much more efficient.
I can press less mouse buttons.
Alright, also Soundgate.
Let me know if everything's okay.
In Ascending Mana Course Cost Order for a combo multiplier.
Okay, so that means I can do more than one card.
When do I use the Pancake?
Oh, can...
Oh, is the Pancake activated now?
Now, like, passively?
Is that what it is?
Is it Q&E to turn?
Oh, it is a passive.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I was trying to do the...
Oh, I still do it.
Okay.
Oh, I don't have enough cards.
Alright, knife time.
An imbibble.
Alright, knife.
thank god all right axe all right let's get the axe oh my
god it's just all bats all right and then oh i don't have
enough fuck i was thinking about numbers as always i was not
thinking about the numbers the numbers hard uh oh wait do i
have left side doki you guys didn't see my okay wait let me
let me go be left side doki i feel like i see my card points
more than my health all right here we go uh i'll do axe the
numbers what do they mean all right oh i like spinach i bash
my head into the problem eventually it'll work
axe and then i should have done spinach first uh as you guys
can see i do not play card games often oops all right
spinach and then axe
okay baby's first card game oh my gosh so many vampires it's
like this place is haunted or think okay Bible holy shit
they're so strong I will do axe Bible as well oh I got water
okay oh my god free water and then more more knife
uh spinach axe all right one more I can live this don't
worry I definitely have I have, like, 100 HP right now.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
5-bat.
Nice spinach.
Good knife.
Are you serious?
Oh, my gosh, I've done...
Okay.
I'm gonna do axe.
Good old axe.
I'm not comboing!
I forgot about the combo!
I'm...
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Thank you, crawler.
But the vampire is in another cast.
God damn it.
You draw a pot of greed of your own.
It's your only chance.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My brain.
That little space in my brain that's supposed to be for
numbers.
It's taken over by Pokemon.
Downhall tracks your unlocks.
Oh, what do I unlock?
Oh, okay.
I rescued Antonio.
In the average Italian countryside.
What can I do with Antonio?
Okay.
Okay, instant movement.
Invert.
Rotate map with player.
Power saving mode.
Is there anything I actually need?
Oh, 500.
Yeah, I gotta need all those frames.
That's for sure.
Screen shake.
Enemy shake.
That's fine.
It's a card game.
I don't think I have to worry about that.
World map.
Okay, let's go for...
Unlock difficulty Mad forest Alright, we go to the Mad
forest Hello bats It's nice Oh, whip Can we get this?
Quachya Quachya Get out of here Oh, okay Matt deals 30
damage Ooh Increase your luck for a chance to get I feel
that let's grab the knife I'll do knife the crit seems
better oh what did I break okay spin it and then whip whip
I'll grab these guys oh armor wait add three armor deal 10%
more damage when a red card is played Triggers five times.
Uh, we'll do armor.
And then the stereo.
Now you can't do shit.
And whip.
Whip.
Thank you, Itonio.
Okay, there's a boss here, so we're gonna get, like, more
cards first before we do anything.
Uh...
let's get more knife oh I should grab the spinner shouldn't
I oh nice I mean I feel like crit is good oh I keep bashing
my head oh oh oh where am I where oh oh I'm back in the back
in there maps are hard it's like where did I go Oh, there's
a strong one.
There's a blue one.
All right, Antonio come to me, Antonio.
I'm gonna call a friend.
Okay, whipped him out.
Holy shit, she lives that?
Don't worry, I have to...
Okay, we'll have Antonio again.
Oh my god, he's so buffed.
Nice, okay.
Yeah, the big bats are scary.
I'm going to try.
Do we get knife or spinach?
I feel like our spinach is really pretty strong, but we
can't even...
Is it like we get more spinach cards?
More knife or Bible?
Okay.
Oh, what is that?
Go dig.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Wait, where am I?
oh that's like i went down okay okay we got more items that
gems the cards find gems and chest or when leveling up okay
that should be like combo oh we got chest it's twice as hard
grab a knife that's where i put that in that knife
i'm scared oh wait there's something over there you see that
Ooh, now they're skellies.
Alright.
All good?
We knew it.
I saw the fire.
I remember that.
Also, do the combos go in now?
Or was that from the last level?
Okay, and then we whip him.
That's fine.
We have the armor.
Oh, I still have the combos.
Okay.
I have two.
Deal eight damage to multiple enemies.
Oh, combos are forever.
Okay.
So, ascent.
So, I should do the ascending order thing.
Uh...
Armor or knife, guys.
Armor or knife?
Armor?
Okay.
I mean, the fire was from the original game, so I assume it
was something.
Whip, spinach, and then Bible.
Okay.
Armor, knife, oh, it did.
Oh, there's a question mark.
What is that?
Oh, plus one mana.
That's good.
Okay, wait, I'm gonna kill these little guys for more money.
Armor, spinach, whip.
That's right.
Antonio, come in here!
Whip him!
A knife.
Alright, I'm understanding.
I'm getting it.
I'm doing combos.
I know how to count more than two.
Okay.
A knife and five.
Let's fucking go.
That's why I'm gaming.
Knife and a spinach.
And a knife again.
They'll never expect a double knife.
Okay, nice.
We got...
Oh, shit.
I wanted to kill the other guy.
That's just chilling.
Whip.
Bye, bro.
Oh, I should have been spinach in them.
Okay, armor, whip, and then double armor.
Uh...
Knife!
Oh my god, free knife!
Let's go!
Antonio, knife, and then knife again.
Okay, the big guy is coming.
The big boss.
Alright.
And then knife.
Okay.
Uh...
Whip...
Knife...
Yeah.
Armor Bible.
Whip.
I'm getting it!
Echonio!
Come over here again!
I need you!
Okay, oops!
I was getting it.
I saw one and I got so excited, guys.
You don't understand.
I saw the one.
I was like, I want to be number one.
Okay, I have more Bible.
I don't think we have a lot of Bibles.
You know what?
Where's the other guy?
Fuck you, Justin.
We killed your dad, but you're coming down with me.
All right, nice.
And just because your dad is dead, doesn't mean I won't kill
you too.
Alright, there you go.
Gotta make sure no survivors.
Alright.
We can't have someone coming in for revenge.
Oh, let's grab that.
Plus two.
Put it on the...
You want the Bible or another knife?
Yeah, no revenge plan.
Lots of that.
No vampire.
This is a vampire survivors.
You gotta crawl your way out of here.
Bible?
Alright, I'll put it on the Bible.
Alright, get down.
Yes.
Deeper!
Alright, we'll kill the bats.
The bats are easy.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, I don't think I need to worry about the other stuff.
a little bit?
Okay, music could probably come up a little bit.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me... Music.
Uh, we'll put it.
Alright, let me know if it's better sound, yeah.
Oh, wait, the boss is right.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's the boss.
He's a zombie.
What?
Alright, let's kill this guy right now.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, wait, they're pretty tanky.
Oh no, okay, wait.
And then this.
I think I can find a chicken.
I'm pretty sure.
We're still early game.
There might be a chicken somewhere.
And then the knife.
Oh, Antonio.
Knife.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even see the bat.
Like double knife armor.
I got leveled up.
Uh...
Spinach or knife, guys?
This feels like this could be...
I think if this was released on mobile, I think they'll do
really well.
It seems like a sitting on the toilet type game.
Sitting on the toilet for more hemorrhoids type game.
The spinach?
Yeah, I'll get the spinach.
Alright, if someone says...
More spinach?
A true...
Okay, please.
Oh no, I need... I need HPs.
Fast.
What about leaning on the toilet?
All right, we'll get plus two.
Put it on the Bible.
Bucket.
Ooh, 80 damage with knockback.
Let's go.
All right, here we go.
Tuesday I put it on the Bible we'll let God take care of it
alright nice so I have the armor okay oh my god 60% let's go
which whip we're gonna teach these guys how to read see I
told you I knew there was gonna be a chicken somewhere oh
there's a little guy Oh.
Okay, nice.
Smash.
One magic wand or spinach?
I feel like spinach, right?
Yeah, I got the power of God in Adamian.
More spinach?
You're right.
You're gonna be buff as fuck by the end of it.
If you're gonna see me, I'll be like 80 times bigger.
Pure muscle.
Okay, now it's just all spinach.
Why don't you leave?
Was that too buff?
Yeah.
Uh, whip.
Oh, I feel like spinach more.
Just because, like, of the, plus, the long term of the
damage boost.
It's just better.
Armor.
And then whip.
Uh.
Bible.
I don't need it.
I don't even think about it.
God will save me.
The spinach, Bible, and then Bible again.
If I'm on God's side, then I can never lose.
And the spinach, and then the...
It's because the times two of it with plus 20% Look at that.
See?
I'm thinking with numbers now.
Alright, deal 20 and then I'm thinking about the long term
here.
Oh shit.
Wait.
I'm still thinking about the long term, guys.
I'm definitely... I have so much HP right now, guys.
Okay.
Just me and you.
It's gonna tank it all This one you're blocked.
Yeah, that's right because I'm blocking the HP because I
have a hundred HP right now You don't have to see it guys.
I definitely have a hundred HP Oh shit
Okay Okay,
yes, oh thank God.
Oh thank God.
Okay, we'll get it Knife.
I don't think we need more knife.
Okay, maybe there's some fire stuff here.
Maybe there's an extra chicken somewhere.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we might...
Wait.
Oh!
If we cash out, do we just get $200?
Or does this give me...
Do I go until I die or do I leave?
What is cash out?
okay yes for what I said two options I oh so I it just gives
me money instead of this I'll take money but keep going oh
I'm thinking about I'll live I'm just thinking I'm gonna I'm
cashing out I'm cashing out.
I don't think I'm going to make it past this level.
Unless...
Never mind.
Oh, unless!
Oh, I thought that was a...
I'm going to cash out.
I'm thinking long term.
I'm thinking about the investments, guys.
It's, um, just money.
There is a chest here.
Don't worry.
I have so much HP right now.
In fact, I have 120 HP.
Don't worry about it.
Whip.
Armor, Bible.
Yeah.
In fact, after this area, I got 120 HP too.
They're like, you're doing so good.
Here's 100 HP.
And I was like, oh, thank you.
I knew I was doing pretty alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay, uh, whip.
all right uh whip spinach bible uh antonio bible bible
double bible okay oh thank god chicken why are there no
chicken okay i'm cashing out i don't i'm cashing out i don't
think i don't think we're gonna get get out of this dungeon.
Net, finish, Bible.
I'm a Bible.
Net, like, 2x net.
I wonder if I can break the tombstone.
I don't know, some of the people might hit money in the
tombstone.
Okay, there's a lot of people there.
Ooh, there could be chicken over there.
We're past this guy.
All right, Antonio...
Hundred and... I'm gonna take that risk.
I'll take the spinach right now.
Oh, no.
Okay.
And then Viable.
And then there's no way that skeleton's living through that.
Can you enter?
I end my turn and I leave.
And I run away.
I don't know, I'm living past this battle.
It's not looking too good.
Oh, no!
It's alright.
It's okay.
I got a lot of money, though.
Oh, what is this?
Reach low 10, collect two mana hearts.
Crawler selection, unlocked.
Ooh, I got the inn.
I got a power-up shop.
Alright.
Unlocked a lot of stuff.
Sorry.
Yeah, that zombie.
hit me for 100 hp there.
Reworld choices.
Add one armor per rank.
Increase duration crawlers saved by one rank.
Gain 20% more XP.
I feel like that.
The growth, right?
I know.
It's so unbalanced.
They gotta patch that real quick.
Always buy the extra gold first.
There's no extra gold though.
I'm like it for the other two.
Growth or damage.
I feel like growth.
I feel like this XP I'm gonna grab the I'm gonna grab that
now I have $10 all right uh oh the end of an ask mighty
crawlers add 15 XP when oh this for like I feel like
Antonio's better when a yellow card when oh gain 15 XP when
she is played actually she is she's never my see like She
has the yellow card.
At 50 XP when Amalda is played.
In 1 XP growth when a yellow card.
She's broken as fuck.
Okay, I trust you guys.
Alright, let's go in.
Back at it again.
Oh, I had the library.
Oh, I had the library already?
Did I finish the Mad Forest?
I guess I did because I got the item.
Is it considered finished if I got the item?
What does that mean?
Oh, no.
Oh, I got the I.O.
I might as well go through the forest again.
I'm going to try the forest.
I'm going to try the forest just to see how she plays.
Orb.
I draw one card and I end my turn.
Uh.
Alright, I'll add 21x.
See?
Potter, oh my God, Potter Greed.
Do I get knife or?
Bible.
Bible?
Oh my God, I got another one.
You're gonna gain three max health destroy.
What?
But what do you mean destroy?
Who are you destroying?
Am I hard?
Do we get...
I can stack each P now?
Oh, one time use.
Oh!
Alright, do we get Hollow Heart or Attractor?
Oh, I get it.
It removes forever.
Attractor?
Pot agreed or Hollow Heart?
Okay, Pot Agreed.
Oh, draw two cards!
Oh my god!
So many cards!
I don't know what to do with all these cards now.
Okay.
Do that.
And then...
I'll draw two cards!
Yes!
And then...
What do I do with all these cards?
And then I'll draw two more cards!
And then...
And I'll do that.
And I ran out of card draws.
Oh, and I can do that.
There you go.
I'll drop cards forever.
You need to attack.
Okay.
Or I can draw two cards.
And then I'll draw two more cards.
This is the green.
I'm using the Exodia deck.
I'll keep drawing.
cards forever all right add what increases area stat wait oh
my god it's rainbow wait what the fuck is rainbow what does
it do like draw three more cards and then and then i just
there's a gem mana for more greed It's shiny, though.
Guys, it's shiny.
Empty tome, but it's so shiny.
Okay, I'll grab empty tome.
And then I draw two cards.
And then I'll add a mana.
I don't need it, but I got armor, though.
Okay.
Imagine I draw two more cards.
then put on my armor and I win.
I thought there was a fire next to me.
Oh, there is a fire next to me.
Oh my god, wait, I think, yeah, she's crazy.
Nah, I understand, guys.
I understand that what you mean when you said she's crazy
broken.
Wait, I got another rainbow.
Oh my god, end golden armor.
Oh my Guys, I got another rainbow!
Oh my god, Dota.
Okay, TPA.
There's so many choices.
I don't know.
They're all so good.
More pot of green.
More mana and more drop.
We must gamba.
But it's so shiny.
Oh my god.
Pod of Green?
500 with images?
Oh shit, drop.
But imagine.
Oh my god.
And I draw two more cards.
Oh, she's dead.
I had to stop drawing cards.
He's already dead.
They're like, stop, Toki.
Please.
Two more cards.
And then what if I draw?
Another two cards.
And then I ran out of stuff.
Um...
Okay, I got the Bible, though.
500 pot of green.
I'm gonna run out of cards to draw by that time.
And then more cards!
And then more!
Oh my god, and more!
And... Oh, I'm done.
Uh...
Now I don't even know what to get.
So much, Creed.
Just keep on drawing cards.
Magic wand?
Alright.
We got the magic wand.
Oh my god.
Can the guy finally hit me yet?
He's just like, please.
Can I finally make my move?
I was like, no!
I need to continue getting cards.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Evolve?
Evolution?
Alright.
Select which card?
Any card?
Alright.
What did I evolve to?
Oh my god, the holy one.
Evolution.
That's right.
My sword.
My sword has been blessed by God.
Grab that and draw two more cards.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
I don't even have the I don't even have the stats to use the
holy one It's okay, but I can draw two more cards though I
could keep on doing it.
Oh Guys apparently I can't do it anymore What if instead of
making a move I draw two more cards oops
Alright there we go Yo, you can't control you need to stop
before it's too late, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat, Tim.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
A spinach, hollow heart, or knife?
You sacrificed the mana for a power you can't even control.
The pot, it's calling me.
oh my god I draw two more cards and I'm magic wand I get max
HP and I'm magic wand
okay holy shit I can go holy wand right now okay two cards
and then magic wand
okay I draw two cards yes Oh my god.
And then the Holy One.
Oh, it's all coming together.
It's all coming together.
The combo.
Who said I can't control the power?
He is speaking to me right now.
I am his prophet.
I am God's chosen child.
I'm the second covenant of Christ.
Oh my.
She's going.
Oh no.
She's going...
The power's going to her head right now.
Gold armor to show your green.
Absolute power corrupts.
Do I get more...
Do I draw more cards?
Or do I get golden armor?
Oh no, she's gotten mad with power!
You're right.
We keep on.
drawing cards what are these those aren't these aren't pots
wait draws a card wait oh my god wait i can draw a card
while using a magic wand let's go card draw more i'm gonna
run out of cards soon oh my god i can draw more cards Let's
fucking go.
It never ends.
Let's put another one in there.
Let's draw more cars.
We're gonna run out, guys.
More.
Oh my god.
We draw a card.
And then we draw two more cars.
And then we do this.
And you only have to draw cars.
Let the engine run.
Oh my god.
We draw a card.
Oh, that's the perfect combo.
We can't do anything about it.
Infinite draw cards.
This is the run.
We draw a card to a draw card and then Holy One.
We created the perfect combo.
I can't be stopped now.
Draw a card.
And then I get free XP.
And then those aren't draw cards.
What are these power-ups?
I've never seen them in my life.
What do any of these?
Dude, I've never seen them before.
All I see are pots and orbs.
I'm the catfish of a certain old man and fought for justice
and totally was not an evil space wizard.
Power!
Absolute power!
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
You're right.
Alright.
And then... Oh my god.
I could get more HP.
Or I can draw two more cards.
And then I'll use the magic wand.
And then I can...
Okay, I should actually use Hollow Heart because I'm
running.
up and then i put on my armor and i draw two more cards okay
and he hits me okay and i draw two more cards and i wholly
want it all right i gotta find myself some chicken soon plus
one mana that's always good i really need to find some
chicken uh where are these not.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Chicken?
I need to find some chicken real soon.
Draw a card and then I draw two more card.
And then I draw two more cards and then I have Holy One.
It's like I'm doing Potter Creed until I find Exodia.
Right now.
This is like, this is actually the Exodia deck and then I
draw two cards and Holy One.
one step one draw step two draw step three question mark win
okay we need empty tome all right we got empty tome back oh
thank god we got the chicken he is not expecting this i draw
two cards get empty tome and then i draw two more cards
again and i grab xp and then I magic wand and I draw two
cards holy wand
empty tomb oh I should have and then I draw a card and I
draw two more cards and then I draw another card holy wand I
draw a card I keep drawing cards empty tomb I draw two more
cards and then king bible and then holy wand Yeah.
First turn kill tech.
Bro, she's so OP, bro.
I...
Only one.
I just keep trying, guys.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, these are all so good, too.
More mana.
Let her cook.
It's so easy.
It's so simple.
And just...
and then holy one oh my god imagine holy one but times two
damage wait oh no really wait can i back it okay i can only
do on bible it's only on bible yes so i can't do double one
they knew they had to stop me they had to put a limiter on
me i had to put on the fucking the fucking Saiyan armor.
The Piccolo armor.
I'm out.
Okay.
It's the...
It's the King Bible.
They put the Piccolo armor on me.
And to think pot of green is banned.
Can't figure out why.
I don't understand.
How could they ban such a beautiful car?
card.
Oh my god, MC Tome.
Draw a card.
Draw another card.
I draw two cards.
And then I draw, get that.
I draw two more cards.
And then I have MC Tome.
And then I, oh.
I could have had it up.
Nice.
They're like, when is it my turn?
Oh.
They had this stupid minion I just have to break my streak.
And then, Holy One.
Get over here.
Alright.
Ooh, empty tome.
Just imagine.
Oh my god.
I draw a card.
Just imagine, guys.
I just keep...
Draw two cards.
Holy One.
Okay.
I draw two cards.
Then I draw another card.
And then I draw two more cards.
And then...
Oh, they took away.
Oh, the Bat's finally here.
It took him a while to get here.
I draw two more cards.
I grab this.
I grabbed King Vibla.
I draw a card.
Holy...
Holy one.
Oh, you're still alive?
How are you still alive?
Oh.
There you go.
Now you're dead.
Goodbye.
Draw to only one.
You admit there's no such thing as too many orbs.
I need more pots.
There's no such thing.
I need more.
And someone give me more.
Okay.
Draw two cards.
Holy one.
Alright.
Now we just Get rid of the little guys.
You're like, where did the big boy boss go?
It was here a minute ago.
Alright, let's see.
Draw two cards.
Draw another card.
Oh my god, I draw two more cards.
I get her.
And then I draw two more cards.
Holy one.
More hearts!
More HP.
Yeah.
How do I do this if I can't draw cards?
I draw another card.
Oh, I don't have Holy One anymore.
Draw two cards.
I draw two more cards.
I get XP.
I get armor.
I'm so scared.
I'm locked in cheese right now.
Come back with your cards with gem slots or cash out.
Okay.
I'll come back.
I used it all up.
Oh my god.
Right into it.
The perfect combo doesn't exist.
They just, they're just begging to get killed right now.
They just want to die so badly.
And then keep drawing cards.
Holy one.
This dude, Doki is too powerful.
She can draw another card.
Cashing out.
Fools!
Actually, you're right.
Maybe I should cash out.
Just for the...
I should just cash out.
I don't need...
I don't need more gems.
I have...
I have my kill cards.
Oh my god, it's, they're just begging to die right here.
They just want to die.
Okay.
Oh shit, I didn't mean to press that.
It just...
Okay, I draw another card.
And I draw another card.
And then I draw another card.
They won't expect this.
And then, what if I draw another card?
Holy water.
and I draw another card and then I get XP
alright do we actually do more damage or just go all in on
Holy One axe?
Axe or empty tome?
But Holy One guy, okay axe and I draw a card and then axe he
even, I don't think he hit me, he was trying to get to me
right now he was Holy Wands?
No!
It's not Holy Wands!
Alright.
He did nothing.
I think he couldn't even touch me.
He's like, when will it be my turn?
And I was like, but what if I draw another card?
What if I just keep on trying cards?
x2 on axe alright let's put that in is she gonna draw
another card find out on the next episode
like surely it's gonna be my turn right oh my guys they just
want to die empty tomb I'll draw another card, put an armor,
and then an axe.
Alright.
Give me your fire.
Draw a card.
Holy one.
What if I draw another card?
And then heart.
And then magic wand.
6 HP.
Draw a card.
Axe.
That just murdered.
That's right.
Alright.
No survivors.
Oh my god.
The free XP.
I'll do Holy One.
Just because it's so strong.
And then we'll do Axe.
Alright.
Draw card.
Bible.
Empty Tome.
Armor.
Come on.
You can get here.
Don't worry.
I believe in you.
You can get over here.
There we go.
Just come on.
Get closer.
I won't bite.
I'll just bite.
Blast you with my holy wand.
It's different.
More magic.
Let's go.
That's what I'd like to see.
I don't even need to put on armor.
Magic control.
Not letting your opponent play their game.
Can't believe Doki is a dirty blue deck player.
Guys, maybe I can play Yu-Gi-Oh.
I'll come back.
Okay.
I'll come back later.
More money.
Oh my gosh, straight out the bat.
They just give me the combo right here.
They just, like, just end their suffering.
Just do it.
Just end it for them.
They don't deserve this.
Don't you love it when they just...
Oh, I could have clicked.
I could have got for the XP.
I got too excited there.
I draw two cards, draw two more cards, draw two more cards,
uh, get HP, and then Baba.
Alright, now you guys can- Oh my god, wait, he hit me.
Wait, that's not supposed to happen.
Wait a minute.
You're not supposed to touch me.
No, no, no.
Wait, I don't like that.
I still don't have a card.
Wait a minute.
They actually got it turned.
Yeah, I'm gonna say how did it get a turn I don't like that
Oh got XP though.
All right golden armor magic wand or whip.
Oh my god.
She got hit She can bleed
She she can bleed guys She's not invincible we have a chance
All right, now I can put this on my card And I can open it
Okay, oh my god, draw a card, yes Yes That's exactly what I
needed Enable me more There we go
Oh, nice, oh good, that was like a chicken I think.
I got my HP back up.
Draw...
Actually, I'll do empty Tome.
And then...
I'll Magic Wand.
And then I'll Magic Wand again.
And I'll draw two more cards.
And then I can do this.
There you go.
Alright, goodbye, flower.
It's guard.
It's weeding season.
I got my pesticides.
Ready.
Okay.
I could empty tome and then grab that and then I get more
mana and then grab two more cards and then grab more mana
and grab two more cards and then magic wand and then grab
three cards and then holy wand and then I can grab armor and
grab two cards and then do that grab another card and grab
another card and then grab armor um and I leveled up
It doesn't stop.
He just flowers just sitting there.
Spinach?
Do we get spinach?
Alright.
And then we grab spinach.
Okay, empty tome.
Grab two more cards.
Grab XP.
Grab another card.
Empty tome.
Totally wide.
an empty tome.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's just all... Okay.
Magic wand.
Grab two cards.
Uh.
Magic wand.
Grab two more cards.
Uh.
I'll do spinach.
Okay.
Empty tome.
King Bible.
And then armor.
Oh no.
He touched me.
Wait.
That's not how it's supposed to be.
supposed to go?
How is he touching me?
Wait a minute.
Who let him touch me?
Yeah.
I grab two more cards.
I get magic.
And then I grab two more cards.
I grab a spinach and an axe and a question.
Oh my god, it's literally right here.
Holy water.
Ow.
Wait a minute.
Who let him near me?
Oh, that's awkward.
I guess we're not coming back.
They're like, come back.
Oh, well, you have a go-oh, I guess I'm cashing out.
I guess it's cash-out time.
Oh, oh, no!
Yeah!
I completely, he's like, you were You were too powerful.
I had to stop you.
God had to send death himself to stop me
She had to be stopped before it's too late That run was
crazy It was the only way The set he sent the Reaper to deal
with me me.
Alright, what do we get?
I feel like we gotta get more growth, right?
God, those the deaf, yeah, deaf himself had to stop it.
It was the only way or the universe would collapse.
The only thing they feared.
I feel like damage, right?
Just imagine.
Oh, the holy one actually came in so clutch.
more XP yeah oh my yeah the holy the holy one it was set up
perfectly for me
armor at least one level all right we'll grab one armor
also heal what is this or is this recovery I mean we can
grab armor and recovery we'll grab armor and recovery cover
here.
I have 500.
Never has the phrase green is good, but more relevant than
now.
Anytime we're in half.
Ballot's art.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll grab this.
Yeah, max HP.
There you go.
Is there any more in the end?
I don't think I need any more.
I think we got the perfect hero.
All right, they're like, please go to the next level.
Wait, but then there's furious forest.
The forest is now even more mad.
I missed my draw card.
Ooh, fire wand.
Wait, fire wand or bible?
Oh, snap.
The madder forest.
That's right.
I'm angry.
born death might have killed my first form but I
reincarnated I'm back for revenge that's right they thought
I would they thought I would be happy in heaven but I came
back I came back I need more fire wand in the forest that's
true our magic wand or knife or Bible you're Red fire is
always good in the forest.
And somehow she returned.
Alright, wand or Bible?
Any?
I'll take the wand.
Alright, fire wand.
I came back.
I was reborn.
I had to finish what I started.
Oh.
Connect and continue combos.
Wait, what?
Oh, I can use it.
Oh.
0, 1, and then Clover, 0, 1, 2...
Oh!
That's cool.
That's neat.
Combos with any card.
Okay.
At 10% luck in this story.
Oh, okay.
Their one-time use returns to hand after playing?
What?
It's so shiny.
Wait, but two mana!
Fuck!
This is so shiny.
I'm going to grab it.
Don't burn out.
You're like, oops.
But it's so shiny, though.
But it's so shiny.
How could shiny be bad?
Okay, I draw two cards.
And now I do this.
If Johnny, how bad?
Okay.
Like, might, maybe?
I'll get the blind.
At 10% might.
Alright, rip him.
The mana armor.
I draw two cards and then 10% might shine me good wait
there's a grave here
now I can see why how this can get addicting I'm just gonna
kill all these guys oh wait they're still alive never mind
oh no they're dead oh no I leveled up garlic to the front
road this arm garlic or light tone I like how they stop
giving me orbs They saw They saw the power I wield Chat
They're afraid They're scared They're so scared They see the
power It's afraid
I'm back I'm back Oh I'm back!
I just need more our orbs and it'll be complete.
Oh, I found a relic.
Unlocks the fortune channel.
The tome didn't insert that.
The legendary return.
Nothing can stop me now!
Alright.
Ooh, crown.
Ooh, empty tome.
Oh my god.
Wait, what XP?
I feel like crown, right?
Oh, but crown!
But crown, though!
But gamma!
It's not gamma!
It's early crown!
Crown, it's an early run.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, wait, there's a chest here.
Next to the boss.
That's nice.
wait can i get like does he put me on my holy wand no it
doesn't double damage okay double uh all personality
evacuate the facility immediately don't he has the holy wand
I don't have to on it on tome though so I think I feel like
x2 maybe for do we do garlic or Garlic or magic wand for
that
Check the cards for might Yeah maybe garlic Alright we'll
put that in garlic
Alright I draw two cards My holy wand And I put armor on And
then Oh my god it's right here Oh my god Alright holy wand
or fire one sorry it feels the same oh my god they just want
to die I guess shit okay guys I could draw another card or I
do light to him oh my god he disappeared he fucking
evaporated
but I could but I could draw more cards guys I could always
Get a tome.
But I could always draw more cards.
Oh, why hesitate?
Or you're right.
Never hesitate on drawing more cards.
We're just putting on magic wand.
We have more greed.
Or area.
Alright, guys.
Which one?
Return area might.
Because we can only put it on magic wand.
Might you don't need area?
Let's go.
Take me down.
My castle is like cash out.
They're like, you don't need more.
Just cash out.
What's the point?
Garlet.
I could draw more.
Oh, I could get Hal's max self, actually.
I think max self.
it's back but it had to be they would draw a card oh all
these choices are so good
oh oh okay this is the only time I draw I take this before
other than how could you do here could you do this hit or
don't worry I'll be back I just had to Just one time.
It was just one time.
Wait, what's the difference between?
That?
Oh, that's a boss win.
Okay.
Add four mana.
Add more armor and then I'll do that.
Okay.
What
do I draw two cards?
Holy water.
It didn't really matter, but...
I still have- I just want to do that.
Okay, that.
I'll do garlic.
Oh, what the fuck he lives?
Holy shit!
Okay, these guys are tanky.
But it's okay.
I can draw another card.
I draw two cards.
Holy one.
I do this.
I add four mana.
I draw another card.
I draw two more cards.
I do garlic.
I get armor.
Magic wand.
Draw two cards.
Holy wand.
I take armor.
Okay.
Magic wand.
Draw two cards.
Light tome.
Garlic.
Fire wand.
Okay.
Armor.
Draw two cards.
Holy wand.
Okay.
Let's draw.
Let's do.
We need more mana or magic wand I don't think we need armor
I don't think armor is in the equation anymore One more Tome
God we need to draw a card Tome Oh my god I can have two
magic Guys Imagine Two holy wands though Two holy wands It's
a trap Guys Two holy ones Oh my god God is good God knows
what's up
Okay I get him out of here Oh nice Oh nice More light tomes.
I draw two cards.
I get more light tomes.
I get golden armor.
And then...
I draw two cards.
Holy, holy one.
Never punish.
Death try to stop me.
But look who's laughing now.
I came back Stronger than ever
Draw two cards Holy One Spinach or more mana Guys Someone's
Nothing can stop me now Spinach or Light Tome Guys More mana
More you're right More mana More Who am I kidding?
Always more mana.
Adds 25 coins.
Combos with any cards.
Draw two cards though.
I could have four mana.
I could draw two cards though.
I could have four.
I draw two cards.
Okay.
I could have eight mana.
I could draw four cards.
I could have eight mana, but I could draw four cards.
I draw four cards.
I could draw two cards, or I should add four mana.
This is the time I should actually add an Inholy One.
Okay, none of these.
Okay, I draw two cards.
I have more mana.
I get Garland.
I got more mana.
Armor.
Oh my god.
The temple only one.
We'll do that.
Holy one.
Okay.
I feel like I have too many holy...
I don't need another axe.
I feel like Bible maybe.
We deal wielding now.
Two holy ones.
I think that's...
At that point, axe is like...
We're on the mana.
You can get zero cry.
I feel like...
like armor for free card you're right i need a free zero
yeah i need that i need the i need the zero for the one okay
grab that i draw two cards i get the armor i have four mana
i draw a card i add more mana i draw another card And then I
draw, I have three mana.
I draw two cards.
My mouse died.
They are trying to stop me.
From drawing more cards.
Okay.
Magic wand, I draw two more cards.
And then holy wand.
Oh shit.
What is that gonna do?
Yeah, I had four mana.
There you go.
Or if she's too powerful, they try to stop me by letting my
mouse die.
Refunds mana.
What can I refund?
Oh, I can refund the mana.
Do we do a refund or increase money?
I feel like refund, right, for the light dome?
Three mana.
Oh, shit.
There was a fucking fire over there.
I wasn't lucky.
Okay, we grab this.
Okay, knife or garlic?
I feel like knife so we can have a free zero.
We're running out of zeros.
Oh, we won.
And they're all dead.
We have too many ones.
Alright.
I'm not too worried about damage anymore.
Damage is just, yes.
Oh my god, it was chicken.
I should have saved that.
I was so used to just smashing my head into light poles.
Knife.
Mana.
Garlic.
Wands.
And then golden armor.
Okay.
Draw two cards.
Holy wand.
oh my god double damage oh my god draw another card oh my
god but double damage do i have enough mana for this
oh my god double damage but then draw a card but orb though
oh my god but it's so shiny
Free Zero?
But Orb!
He needs to cycle for...
Greed, you're right.
I should never betray Greed.
Sacrifice cards at the correct color to unlock.
Okay.
I do have a lot of y'all.
Okay, we can get rid of.
Okay.
and what do we get rid of well obviously one of them has to
be the orb but do we get rid of the golden oracle armor or
the regular armor chat the gold one gold armor and one all
right and then one this what do we get oh my god it was
worth it we draw a card we draw It's so worth it.
That...
We draw a card.
We never stop.
Oh my god, we get refund, too.
And then refund, and then holy one.
Free draw.
Never punished.
Doesn't really matter what we use, honestly.
Okay.
Knife so we can draw a card.
card and then we draw another card and then holy one
I can't keep getting away with this oh my god the double
holy one all right we gotta get this so we do the holy one
and then we attract another card and then we get a garland
here oh we can get more we get more mana oh more mana Yeah,
we have the luck.
Alright, give me your chest.
It's a draw card.
What does it add to?
Oh, this is my light dome.
Alright.
Do we want might, area, or armor?
Oh, get might.
Might, alright.
Put it on my light dome.
Alright, money.
This is so easy.
Draw two cards Holy One Get armor Get XP Buy one Holy One
And then magic Nice Oh I could Draw another card Okay Mana
Clover Magic?
Totally why.
There you go.
Oh, he's right there.
Oh, hey.
Free upgrade.
Hermit stat boost.
I should cash out.
I'm cashing out.
I don't need armor.
I absolutely do not need more armor.
Oh, there it is.
Plus one.
Oh, plus one mana.
That's what we need.
I'm gonna keep this.
Actually, should I keep it?
I could do mana, clover,
12 armor, and then holy wine.
Oh my god, that was crazy.
That actually went crazy.
And I can get more...
That actually went fucking crazy.
All right.
Banana knife or orb, guys.
I don't know.
We have too many orbs and we need zero.
Is there such thing as too many greed?
You're right.
There's no such thing as too many orbs.
You're so right.
You're so fucking right, guys.
There's no such thing.
What are you talking about, Toki?
You're so right, guys.
How could I be foolish to think that?
Alright.
He has to walk closer.
He's so far away from me.
It's just all the strong cards now.
And then grab two more cards.
And now grab armor.
Yeah.
Mana.
Armor.
Mana again.
And then more mana.
Oh no.
guys I think I have too many drunkards I might have too many
hey refund the mana please no you don't they can't stop you
nonsense keep trying what at tumor mana no I don't think it
matters what order i do for this oh wait i win never punish
never fucking punish one two magic one all right oh my god i
could have another holy one just to that guy okay i think i
have too many holy ones now i i legitimately think i have
too many holy
Never doubt the greed.
I got more, more wands, so what if I had three only wands,
guys?
Imagine.
Imagine if I had three.
Actually.
Get out of the way.
We're going to refund the dome.
I do believe that we might have too many.
I don't think we need three magic wands.
Boo!
We want more magic wands!
More wands!
Okay.
Even Dad's like, more wands!
okay draw a card magic wand you draw another card magic wand
okay draw a card mana and then just more of that okay and
then holy one more ones I don't man more one you think there
is such a thing as too many draw a card holy one garlic oh
wait duplicate fires one more okay wait okay you stop
barking i'm gonna say all right spinach we i don't think
okay i have to feed them real quick guys
oh i'm back i'm back guys all right which one do we get
duplicator or spinach guys duplicator or spinach chat dupe
duplicator all right i don't know what we duped okay we draw
a card we add more mana we match it one we draw two cards We
add more mana.
We draw two more cards.
Armor.
I legitimately don't even think we...
Oh, I could have eight armor.
Let's just grab that.
Add four armor and more magic.
Okay.
We draw a card.
Holy wand.
Get XP.
Magic.
Oh, we could draw two more cards, though.
Do I do damage or draw two more cards?
Decisions, decisions.
I could get empty tome.
Okay, I did not get an empty tome.
We're just gonna do more small damage.
Draw two cards.
Magic wand.
Holy wand.
Always draw card.
Always gamma.
You don't know what you might get.
Oh my god, it's just all magic.
Like, what am I going to do with all this magic?
Draw two cards.
Holy one.
I could draw another card.
No.
Oh my god, the werewolves are here now.
Okay, fire's two more projectiles.
I can draw a card.
I can draw another card.
I can magic wand.
another card.
And I can magic.
And I draw two more cards.
And then I can magic again.
And then
I can draw two more cards.
And I can have armor.
And then the XP.
Oh my god.
It's not going so.
This might be it.
Okay.
I can't have a card.
Santa water?
Burns at enemies after this turn.
Stop trying.
cards.
You're right, the combo.
That's a water.
Guys, but what if I draw two more cards?
Guys,
but what if so?
Imagine if I draw two more cards.
Just think about it.
It would be so funny.
Let's draw two cards.
Holy one.
But what if I keep drawing cards?
Think about the possibilities.
Reduce armor.
I'm caching out.
Okay, there is one.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's just a coin bag, though.
God, I need food so bad.
It'll never be over.
As long as I can keep drawing cards.
Oh my god.
There you go.
It finally stopped.
Oh my god, it's just all ones.
Oh my god, I might have made a mistake.
It's just all ones.
Okay.
I'll just get rid of these.
guys okay we might need more zeros i think i think we might
need more zeros i i think there's a possibility that we
might need more zeros guys but just a maybe
okay there holy one the food oh my god thank god okay not
never punished all right we got food It's not as bad now.
Okay, these werewolves go fucking hard right now.
If only I had more draw cards.
Okay.
There is refund here.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Armor.
Draw two cards.
Duplicator Magic wand Draw two cards Armor Golden Tome Armor
Alright, it's all We're all in on armor Oh my god, okay Draw
a card Holy wand Refund Santa water Okay XP Okay Duplicator.
Golden armor.
Magic wand.
Oh, this is getting harder now.
We gotta draw a card.
Yelp.
Garlic.
Nice.
Knife or magic wand?
Chat.
Knife, right?
Would knife be better?
We don't have a knife.
Right.
now.
Axe, we have a lot of holy wands.
I think we're fine.
I think we're fine with the holy wands.
Knife or wand?
Axe has knockback?
Okay, wand.
Alright, nice.
Alright, let's see if we survive this boss fight.
Yeah.
Magic wand.
Oh, I could do duplicate.
I'm going to do duplicator for the holy one and then draw
two cards Okay
Knife Oh my I could have done the sack of water too All
right, give me Oh my god, could have
Or get armor.
Oh my god, but wait Oh, if I... Oh, actually, it wouldn't
matter because it gets... It's four mana, right?
It wouldn't even matter, though, because... I feel like
armor.
Really evolved?
Because I only have one Santa water.
Holy one.
Yeah, so I wouldn't have a three anymore if I evolved it.
We're not getting another holy one, guys.
We're not getting another holy one.
Guys, I can barely afford.
I can barely afford it anymore.
Alright, we're getting armor.
Guys, I cannot afford it.
I can't afford another holy wand.
I can barely use the one we have.
I'm not made of wands, guys.
I wish I was.
And then...
Okay.
Alright, I try to make sure I don't...
I don't waste it all.
And then...
Light Tome.
Armor.
I draw two more cards.
Duplicator.
Santa Water.
And then Armor.
Okay.
guys we cannot get another we have to get more zeros guys i
i can't get i'm gonna grab a whip i would guys i i would
love to but i think we've actually made i'm pretty sure
we've made it so that we can't afford this anymore i know i
really really want to i think i think there is such a thing
as too much match too much greed i I didn't want to believe
it at first but I'm starting to believe that there is such a
thing as too much greed I didn't want to believe it too guys
I didn't think it was possible saying so so it ain't so what
the fuck is he doing here the creep comes with a nonsense.
Okay.
It is done.
Oh my god.
That's so much damage.
Okay, holy one.
I gotta do that plus two R.
Holy shit, okay.
He's dancing.
He's dancing up my grave.
Okay.
I'm actually have to get the golden armor.
Okay, I'm gonna grab that.
Okay, holy one.
Oh my god, get out of here.
No, no, don't hit me.
Okay No, I'm footstrap.
No My combo oh it didn't matter never punished never
punished it didn't matter.
Oh Thank God that scared me.
Oh my god guys.
I cannot I cannot level up anything guys.
I cannot Never punished Okay Oh I don't think I'm gonna live
through this encounter.
I might not have a lot of HP, guys.
There is a chance that I might not have a lot of HP left.
Just a maybe.
Okay.
I need more knives.
Oh god.
okay I'm just going all in on the
okay can't see the HP oh I have like 800 HP right now
everything's alright just 800 HP for sure draw a card I'm
gonna grab armor and then only holy one draw two card magic
one okay grab a little magic one here refund this uh the
holy one more mod hold just just just stack it in
track the Holy one.
Okay, we lived another day.
Yeah, but never full.
Oh, I wish that was a chicken.
Oh, I didn't mean to start.
Okay.
We started it.
We accidentally start the fight.
Okay, armor.
Let's add some...
Let's add that in there.
We gotta lock in.
Alright.
I can't I would love to I would I would love to get more
draws oh my god maybe the three extra help help will come in
clutch guys no don't tempt me you're right you're right I do
need it you're so right guys i so need this how could i
doubt you all
oh why are they still alive why are they still alive
okay oh all right chat build chat guild
What would I do about Chapfield, guys?
What would I do about you all?
Oh, he comes the big boy.
The big boy is coming.
Oh, there he is.
He's here.
Oh, I fucked up.
I could have holy water.
It didn't count.
Why do I have...
Why do I always keep not counting?
Oh, my God.
What did he destroy?
Oh, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
I'm not going to risk it.
gonna risk it.
He gave you a present.
I could draw a card.
Magic wand.
Oh my god, there's still more.
It's not worth it.
I'm not going down there.
It's not triple wand.
So, oh please, I need a chicken.
I don't need money.
I just need a chicken.
Please!
One chicken!
Oh no!
Okay.
I'll grab the armor just in case.
Just in case something happens to me.
Okay, oh my god.
Guys, do you think crown would even be worth it?
It didn't end.
We'll try it.
Fuck it.
Oh, fuck it.
We'll go all in.
Shit.
I don't have any projectiles to fire!
It doesn't matter.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay I helped Yes, that's a water
Draw two more cards
And then okay there we go
Okay I'm thinking right now Then the refund and then more
refund and then draw a card one Grab a golden armor just in
case.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, there's so many.
There's so many.
Okay.
Got you merged.
Holy one.
Suplicator.
Garlic.
All right, two left.
This is just...
There are just many boys, too.
Two.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, oh my God.
Maybe that they have chicken in the grave.
Maybe the grave has some chicken for me.
They might put chicken in there.
I believe.
The graveyard chicken.
Okay, guys.
Which one?
which one water all right got the free water I draw two more
cards and then garlic oh thank God okay okay they're getting
a lot closer now they're getting a little too close for my
liking the duplicator on this
I can refund this.
I draw a card.
And then I think I have to go golden armor.
I need the extra armor for these guys.
I might need it.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I did it.
I got too scared.
They were getting way too close.
Draw a two card.
That four mana.
Draw another two cards.
A deholy water.
another Santa water and then I'll magic wand
oh I need my oh god okay whatever she's here now I did not
mean to do that whatever she's here now
got two cards armor garlic I mean it doesn't really matter
there's two more guys left Oh, please don't tell me.
Oh, God.
Don't get close to me, please.
Chicken?
Oh, no, chicken.
Please tell me I need chicken.
I need chicken so bad.
What can I put on this?
Oh, I could.
Oh, but it's like, I don't think I have enough.
Oh, you guys decide.
I'm committed to chat, Phil.
Oh, wait, draw a card.
Oh, hey.
Let's draw a card.
All right, let's draw another card, guys.
Please, I just...
One chicken, please, is all I asked for.
Where are all the chickens?
Where did they all go?
Okay.
Let's draw a card.
Holy one.
Alright.
I think we need more mana.
We'll grab another leg toe.
Okay.
Draw two more cards.
Holy one.
And then draw two more cards Armor Duplicator And then There
Oh fuck okay Uh Magic wand Light Tome Armor Draw two cards
Refund Santa wand doesn't really matter what I would I do
for this honestly I said oh my god alright alright thank God
for armor thank God got two cards draw a card draw another
two cards magic duplicator oh I should oh I don't even know
what I'm doing anymore what am I I doing?
Oh my god, what am I doing?
It's all blurring together!
Draw two cards.
Oh my god.
Alright.
There's too many stuff on my screen!
Okay.
We're okay.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
My game My game crashed.
My game crashed.
No.
My run.
I cooked too hard.
The, they intervened.
The build.
I drew it too hard.
to the sun it was too strong oh i'm back i'm back baby i'm
back oh my god i don't even
i'm back stronger than ever
let's go we're so back
We're so fat, guys.
Never punished.
I chose so close to the sun.
I should get this.
Okay.
I have to get that.
Doesn't even matter.
I can have an extra armor, though.
Okay.
And draw this card.
Get a life tone.
Get that.
Draw another card.
Draw two more cards.
Empty tome.
Okay, all armor.
All in on armor.
Fuck, okay.
Okay, okay.
We can get more XP.
Oh, it lasts for the battle?
Okay.
I think we might need the armor, honestly.
Crown or... Crown?
During... Guys, we're not surviving enough.
I don't know.
Okay, armor.
Yeah, I have four mono right now.
I could.
I'm gonna draw a card.
And draw another card.
Santa water.
Grab the armor.
And then here.
Okay, good.
The armor came in clutch.
Add a mana.
Add this.
Armor.
Draw two cards.
Draw two more cards.
Armor.
Garlic Santa water.
Oh, only there?
Oh, that's fine.
I'll take those.
That poor mana with Duplicator.
Holy water.
Draw one card.
Knife.
Mana.
Magic wand.
Golden armor.
Okay.
Draw two cards.
Alright, it's just all this.
Okay.
to get another one.
Okay, but what if we draw another card and then we refund
that and then we throw that in here?
Okay, he was just going to be dead anyway.
I should have just threw that.
I should have just I think I might actually need more two
plus two cards.
You're right.
It's not chicken yet.
Still no chicken.
Okay, mana.
Draw another card.
Add more mana, knife, armor, magic wand, fire sword.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Armor, golden armor, sense of water.
Garlic.
Oh, none of them died.
Oh my god, none of them died.
Okay, we keep drawing cards.
Holy water.
Empty tome.
Duplicator.
Draw another.
Holy water.
We will be drawing another water.
Keep drawing water.
I'm getting confused now.
Uh.
I don't know if I'm cooking anymore.
I don't know.
Bible, you're right.
We need knockback.
You're so right.
it very fun get out of here okay Jesus Christ the holy water
got that armor in me get that in another holy straw cart and
then garlic and an extra whip and then we draw another card
and i end my turn oh i have no more zeros i i have no more
zeros it's all ones guys i might have invested too much on
the ones guys do you think i flew too close to the sun with
all the ones not yet don't you never give up it's not yet
Let me get these guys out of here.
She's alive.
I guess for those who don't know, I may or may not have been
on 4 HP.
This is the last two areas.
I am so desperate for some chicken right now.
Oh my gosh.
Stop giving me money.
just don't get it oh my god oh my god yes oh my god yes I
will sacrifice a card I will absolutely sacrifice a card oh
my god no way no way okay I think I know exactly what I
should sacrifice I think we might need a sacrifice perhaps
an orb never punish we a mad a card really oh but the armor
has been so clutch guys no not the orb don't you don't do it
Oh my god.
Oh, we might have.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
It had to be done.
We might need, we had to do it.
We can't greet him.
We're dead.
Exactly.
Alright, here we go.
I'm not fighting the other three.
I don't think I would live.
Okay.
Oh, I should have grabbed golden armor.
Oh, my God.
I should have grabbed golden armor.
I don't know what I was thinking.
I don't know.
I was not.
I was not thinking at all.
Oh, thank God.
Knife or spinach or crown?
Knife or spinach, guys?
Spinach?
Okay.
I can't do this.
And then, and draw a card.
And I can grab that, and I can do that.
And I can get Golden Arbor.
Oh my gosh, I should have saved it for the Santa water.
What the fuck was I thinking?
I wasn't.
I wasn't thinking!
That's the thing.
Okay.
Get sad, get this.
Alright, and then we can get holy water.
Okay.
Oh, my god, he's getting closer.
He's getting so close.
Another card.
We can draw another card.
We can get holy water.
And then we get fire water.
Oh, he's getting so close, guys.
He's getting way too close for me.
Okay, I could get him out of here.
I'm gonna do it.
okay oh god only have one zero
i have so much santa i'm gonna use it all up use up all the
santa water all in on the golden armor oh he does so much
damage oh my god he's so much armor oh my god i actually
live because of that draw a card
oh my god we did it Holy shit, we did it!
Holy shit, we did it!
Okay, fire wand or whip?
Fire wand or whip?
Yes.
Oh, I did it, I lived.
We won zero?
This, that's it.
Okay, I need more zeros, you're right.
Oh, we survived.
Survived yet again.
We live another day.
Deal armor as damage when played?
What does that mean?
Evolve?
Just do it.
Alright.
Let's just get this just for the sake of it.
Oh my god.
End my suffering.
It's okay.
I will come back stronger.
end my suffering.
He's here.
Oh my god.
All the achievements.
Let's go.
Just how many achievements you want.
I played purple cards a hundred times.
This is only my third game.
Only one.
Oh, how much money did I make?
I'll grab more XP, not gonna lie.
I think the XP came in fucking clutch.
I'm getting the hang of it, guys.
I can, I see now.
I see the addiction.
Check all the new buildings.
Okay, but what do we want to upgrade?
Might?
Oh, yeah, all right, we didn't get that.
Oh, new tent.
Oh, yeah, there's new tent powers.
I forgot.
Where's the tent?
Do I need to pay for it?
Keep up to five mana between terms.
How many can I equip?
Oh, I can only equip one.
What do we want?
Keep up to the region.
Which one is it?
This one?
Wait.
Healing.
This one, double healing.
Or sharp mana.
this one all right I'll grab sharp mine oh and that's not
what I wanted
all right we have $600 left what can we upgrade
we could get one HP after each encounter or re-roll choices
luck someone said luck is not worth it Grab the heart?
A recovery?
Okay, we'll put recovery.
Alright, now I'm broke.
Alright.
What's after scary forest?
We never leave the forest.
You're like, please leave.
Please go to the library.
I'm like, no!
I must continue to the forest!
I'll do another.
All right, fine.
I'll do a library.
We never left the forest.
All right, let's see.
Let's grab a Bible.
Oh, and oh, candle.
Attack, steal.
All right, candle.
I feel like crown.
I'm going to grab crown.
Crown for the XP.
Early XP.
Yeah, early crown is always good.
And then we get luck too.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Oh, fuck, not the giant.
That was an accident.
I'm so used to just bashing my head.
Draw a card.
Always.
No hesitation.
Oh, another one.
What?
Choose a reward.
Yeah.
a weighty tome?
I'll get a two just for the combo, right?
Oh, leave.
Okay, we'll leave.
Oh, yeah, I can get Holy Wann after.
You're so right, guys.
Alright, spinach, fire wand, or knife?
Which one?
I don't even need more zeros or five.
Spinach, knife.
I have another zero.
Alright, knife.
I'll do knife for the zero.
We can't level it up yet.
Oh, there's the monster, Guru.
Babu.
Oh my, I'm like speedrunning this.
It's in my nature.
I was born to do this.
To just keep drawing cards.
It was who I was meant to be.
Oh my god, I just keep drawing cards.
drawing cards.
Alright, garlic.
I'm going to do garlic.
It's because I heard garlic's pretty good.
I was born to...
I was born to draw cards!
Oh, I need the light tone.
Okay.
Sage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I believe in the heart of the cards.
I continue to believe.
I can evolve.
Wait, I can evolve.
The holy one is back.
God will always be by my side.
And then garlic.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, another crown.
Let's go.
Bam.
Another crown.
And we need a tome.
And then we'll get a duplicator next to that.
Oh my, a quick draw.
Wait, refund.
Yellow.
Adds a yellow color.
What if it's yellow?
Oh, wait.
They're all good.
Which card, though?
None of these are good enough.
God doesn't kill you.
Then why did he give me the holiest of wands?
Okay.
yellow we can make it yellow quick draw is insane yeah but
then we don't really have good quick draw cards though
or yellow card is more speed that's true we should put as a
knife then or king bible bible or knife we don't have a tome
tome i would put that on a tome refund is great i'll put it
in a bible then
all right refund on Bible or yellow on Bible or yellow on
garlic I'm
put on got Bible give me a down I'm ready if somebody's over
here nice all right give me my refund easy I get it now I
get this game why this game has 6,000 reviews that's right
I'm gonna start my own dual island oh it's time to pot oh
plus one I get rid of oh fuck I don't even know what to get
rid of but this is a zero uh get rid of armor I think I can
get another armor card soon.
Oh, light tome.
Yeah, see, golden armor.
Armor has been clutched, though, for me, late game, though.
Armor, light tome, or whip.
I do need more ones.
I think light tome.
Because I used it to...
I used it earlier, I remember.
Yeah, I need more zero cards.
I'm like, no.
Need more zero cards, guys.
I'm running out.
Oh, now there's ghosts.
Oh, I could have just grabbed that.
Oh, shit.
Holy one.
Oh, no, they touched me.
Crown?
Holy one.
Magic one.
Garlic?
Grab the refund.
And then track the card.
And then...
Nice.
Oh my god, it's all crowns.
Of eyeball.
Shows breakable light sources on the mini-map.
Oh.
Oh, oh, it's the lights.
Don't worry, these will kill me.
It doesn't kill him!
What is garlic?
Was garlic alive this entire time?
What do you mean it doesn't kill him?
Rainbow armor?
Guys.
But it's rainbow.
We do need more zeros though.
I feel it.
Guys, but it's rainbow.
Guys.
It's so sparkly.
Yeah, I'm getting it.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't really do anything for me.
But it's rainbow.
And that's good enough for me.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
It's hitting me now.
All right.
Yeah, that's right.
Now you can't do shit.
That's right.
Let me
do the Bible.
Rainbow too strong.
I think I need more twos.
I'm going to grab the axe just for the two.
Oh, oh, wait.
You get the extra chest.
Wow, the card.
This card will always benefit from combos.
Wait, what do these two mean?
Stick it on a zero?
Wait, leader?
Where's leader?
Attack, steal, wilder card.
Oh, so if I have this card in my hand, it'll always do more.
Okay, easy combo.
Easy combo keeps the boost, but can still end the combo.
You don't have to go in mana cost order.
Okay.
I should put it on the garlic.
I feel it.
Oh, throw it on the end of...
Oh, for extra power.
Oh, I see.
Alright, we'll put it on the knife.
Oh, get out of here.
Give me your XP.
Oh my god, another crown.
my god i'm so rich let's grab it brought the
draw card bible holy wine mug earns coins when the card
kills an enemy
do you like that you do like that it is rainbow though guys
but it's rainbow guys guys it's rainbow guys guys it's so
beautiful me like money but me me like money but I'll get
the duplicator I guess I guess
Oh, wait, what?
Did it not?
Oh, it ended the combo.
Okay, I was so confused.
Alright, that out of here.
Little garlic him.
I thought it continued it, but it also ends it.
Whoops.
Oh my god, get more.
More XP.
That's fine.
I'll grab extra armor, too.
And
then...
Do I need more zero or do I want to draw another card?
I want to draw another card.
Alright, get in here.
Ooh, I get another easy combo.
I could put it on the garlic.
Or...
Alright.
Do we want easy combo or leader?
I feel like I should put it on the garlic.
Or the axe.
Or, axe?
Alright, we'll put it on the axe.
Alright, down, I'll go.
Draw a card.
I draw two more cards.
I throw it on the axe.
Oh my god, I'm so healthy.
And then armor, and then garlic.
Easiest combo of my life.
Duplicator or knife.
zeros chat i don't even know i've lost count i've more
duplicator i'm more duplicator imagine guys three axes oh my
god that's a chicken i don't need i don't need heals yet not
yet
okay i helped and i can duplicate that
draw two cards you can add more knife and i can duplicate it
and then get more armor
Refund?
Easy.
That's right.
Keep stacking.
I'm so hungry.
I want more!
More!
Oh, refund.
Grab it on the toe.
More.
So hungry.
Feed me.
Feed me more cards.
Oh shit, whoops.
Alright.
It still works.
That'll be like...
Is this a challenge?
Alright.
Nice.
More luck.
It's where the chicken is.
And we destroyed that.
How the fuck did he hit me?
That's fucking right.
Wand or armor?
I don't think we need more max health.
No, the question mark was the chicken boof.
That's why I didn't go for it.
Fire one?
All right, we'll go with fire one.
And then axe.
More luck.
More draw!
Evolve!
Alright, Duplicator Armor.
Light Tome Axe 1.
Okay, Holy One.
I do need- I feel like I might need Vacuum.
Draw one card.
Nice.
Candle or Empty Tome chat.
Attacks- I feel like Candle, right?
Candle or Empty Tome?
Candle?
Alright.
Draw two cards.
Nice.
Wan.
Garlic.
Duplicator.
Again.
Magic Wad with 480.
I like the sound of that.
Liked home.
Holy Wad.
Oh, I could have added the axe too.
Just for funsies.
Oh, card is copied.
Always benefits.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, copies garlic.
I don't need that.
1k damage.
Yeah, but the copy is on garlic and firewall.
And I don't think that's good.
All right, put the easy combo on something here.
Yeah, but yeah, it's not on tomes.
It's on these.
on the garlic.
down I go.
More combos.
More luck!
Guys, I think I might actually...
I might need more zeros, honestly.
Tomer won.
Yeah, I went too hard on the woods.
We gotta diversify.
Juan?
All right.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that damage sound you gave me there.
I might have to die for that.
Oh, no.
Nice.
And an extra left on the way, too.
It's okay.
I can get my HP back slowly.
Okay, maybe there's a chicken over there.
Nope, but more luck, though.
More luck!
Did you say more luck?
I did not, but thank you.
Oh, they're so tanky now.
Oh, this is bad.
They're actually really tanky now.
I actually might need...
Okay.
I might need chicken.
I might need some chicken or some armor.
These guys are... I might need knockback or something.
Oh, my gosh.
of water yes okay that's good actually kills never mind that
does not kill that does not kill it's okay that for some
reason does not kill oh they're doing so much damage we're
not looking too good I didn't realize how much damage it
scales now
Oh, no.
Don't touch me.
Don't touch.
No!
Oh, no.
It just done.
Okay.
Oh, I need more draw cards.
That's what I'm lacking.
I realize.
Oh, there we go.
I think we're missing the orbs.
We are.
I need more orbs.
Give me more orbs.
No!
Wait, do 100 damage?
Bombard its enemies after every turn.
Okay, bombardment.
Wait, that's cool.
Adds three mana.
Okay, Bible or atome?
I think we...
Bible or atome, guys.
Bible for knockback?
Okay.
Oh my god, all right.
All right, I'll get our maybe armor.
I'll do armor I need more armor honestly.
I actually might need armor That was so much XP.
Oh, please tell me there's a chicken hidden in there.
Oh Not chicken, but that's fine.
Maybe some chicken in here.
Nope, not chicken, but that's okay
Only one Just gonna keep doing that I keep knocking them
away
All right, good Oh!
Alright, let's see if we live here.
Armor, Bible, and then water.
Oh, yeah, we live.
We fucking live.
Alright, Tome.
Or Bible.
Or armor.
I don't know, we need more zeros or a Tome.
Tome, okay.
Oh shit, goodbye.
Did he just casually explode?
Oh shit, that was a zero.
Whoops.
Alright, as long as...
Oh, goodbye!
Okay.
Alright, she should explode another one.
Nice.
Magic one.
Attract the orb.
Axe.
garlic XP so oh all right might have messed up
okay I okay I might this might be over this might be over no
I wasn't greedy enough guys I wasn't greedy enough Oh my
god.
I should have been more greedy.
I can't even upgrade.
I'll do the roll.
We need more greed.
No, not this one.
Where is it?
Why use another character when she's so good?
As 10, Ariel.
Ariel and Poe is played.
Draw one card when a blue card is played.
But isn't she the best one?
That wasn't greedy enough.
I should have went with more Orm.
The one time I didn't go with Orm.
The one time.
I feel like the others are not as good.
Needs to play the character to unlock cards.
Okay, we'll grab...
area when increases hand by one when a purple card.
Which one should I do?
I can only buy Po or Pasqualina.
Which one is better, chat?
He is more expensive.
He plays with garlic.
Knife guy.
I don't have enough.
I'm broke.
I mean, I could get enough, actually.
I'll get rid of.
Are we refund that?
Does it refund everything?
I just want to refund this.
Oh, Pasqualina is pretty good.
Okay, I'll try her.
Great power.
Alright.
Let's go, uh, a nerd to go to the library.
I don't know if she can ever live up, though, to attack
sealed 10% splash damage.
Okay, knife, king, bible, magic one.
Um...
Go on.
Just for the knockback.
I feel like we'll need it.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know if she can live up to greed.
Greed was just so good.
Getting 10%.
I'll get the mask.
So at least I can be rich.
If I die, at least I can die rich.
My luck is done.
There we go.
That was an insane combo.
Oh, man.
I wish I could find crowns, though.
The crown run was so good, too.
More stone mask.
More money.
If I can't have XP, I'll have money.
Yeah.
She draws a card every time you play a blue card.
What?
Did she get to hit me for free?
Alright, more money.
Oh, oh, crown.
It's fine.
We got crown, though.
No!
I'm so used to just bashing my head into things.
Oh, I don't have the combination yet.
I'm so used to it.
I don't look both ways when I start hitting my head draw
card wait do we want more draw cards guys draw cards or it
might is this also a draw card angle chat is it is it guys
it's another draw card angle i don't know
do we keep being greedy okay i don't know for her if she's a
draw card smeta or not
All right.
Okay, then we draw another card.
Oh, it doesn't hit the same, though, guys.
All right.
Guys, I know what I miss.
I miss the Holy One.
It's not the same.
What about the Holy One, guys?
It doesn't give me the same rush.
You know?
The dopamine rush is not there When the wand starts getting
holy
Oh my god, he's still alive
Alright, he's dead, never Does his armor work or does that
have to be a zero armor
Does golden armor work?
Any armor?
Okay, we'll use that Ooh, we'll get Stone Mask.
Yeah.
Alright, we should be able to evolve now.
Evolve!
Yes!
Do more damage!
I don't know if it'll give me the same rush, though.
Ooh, gross.
Wait, does that...
Wait, does that increase my XP if I use it?
Is that what it means?
Guys?
Oh, not permanent?
Broke good?
Maybe.
Alright.
I like maybe.
Those are the odds I will take.
I'll take that gamma.
The 50-50 on maybe.
Let me draw one card.
Maybe?
I like the sound of that maybe.
okay we'll go this way
I can't even use it I don't have enough I don't have enough
mana for this
I'll just use that just because I can't
alright nice oh my god I got another one but I can't even
use it it was right there
alright can't know or light to him chat I think like light
to him that card truly has no future unless oh it heard you
he heard you he was like who said i have no future he heard
you all right
there you go the cards the cards speak all
right let's see Oh, I need more twos, though, for sure.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I didn't mean to do that, but I guess we're going in.
Nice.
Uh...
I could get 10...
I could get more coins, though.
I could get more coins.
I could get even more rich, though, guys.
Do I draw a card or be more rich?
Okay.
Alright, alright, fine, fine.
Next time I see that stone.
even though I'm grabbing that stone card.
Ooh, easy combo.
Easy combo.
Came in clutch last time.
I draw two cards.
Empty tome.
Let.
And then Bible.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's just all ones.
It's just...
I mean, I guess that works.
It's just all ones.
I might need some...
Well, I keep drawing zeros as my card see it candle draw
card and then no future we need twos though we need twos oh
you know what i'm greedy i want money give me that 70
percent
okay and
then no future oh I have rerolls you're right I forgot but
the money I spent rerolled you're so right okay next time we
use rerolls
oh shit
we got that We always get no future.
Oh my god, a crown.
Yes, please.
More XP.
Smash my head.
More money.
More greed.
Never punished for being greedy.
Oh, can't use any of those.
Whoa, whoa.
Guess I got punished for being too greedy.
Oh, but what if XP's out?
Oh, no.
I can't even use this.
It's right there.
Greed is good.
Okay, nice.
Money.
If I draw that, I can get that.
And I can grab that.
Okay.
Candle.
Tome.
Grab a card.
Oh, oh, fuck, I couldn't grab.
No, I couldn't grab mana.
I keep thinking I have enough mana, but I don't.
I'm so poor.
I keep thinking I'm so...
much money but I only have I'm only rich in coins all
right there you go the lack of twos it's hurting so bad oh
my god there's a two oh this we'll grab that we need that.
We actually really need that badly.
Oh, look.
Okay, armor, return growth.
Put that on there.
Now we have some twos, though.
Oh my god, finally!
Finally, I can use this!
Grab another card.
Grab a Clover.
And a no future.
Okay, good, good, good.
Clover Axe, guys.
Clover Axe.
We need a twos.
We're so broke.
The unlimited power.
We finally unlocked it.
Axe, all right.
All right, this should be it.
Oh, never mind.
He wants to go again.
Zero.
Or combo.
Axe.
This.
That should kill him.
We just needed that.
That too actually clutched it.
Alright.
We have reroll.
Oh!
Let's go.
I might amount.
I hit twice as hard.
Let's put that on the axe.
Bam!
Let me in.
I bash my head hard enough to let me in.
I can't say no.
Okay, zero, this, zero, this, it's fine.
I got the XP.
All right, how do I do this?
Okay.
I can do that.
To do the tome, I have more magic.
Oh, fuck!
I forgot the feature.
Whoops.
Oh, it's okay.
Not punished.
Get more greed.
Level up.
Oh, mana.
Okay, I really needed the mana, too.
No!
Not the chicken!
I just never expect a chicken ever!
I feel like the chicken was never gonna come!
Oh, I need more zeros.
We can't do this.
Okay.
Ooh, duplicator.
Alright, let's grab a duplicator for once.
This is bad.
I just never expect it Weapon fires plus more Do I sacrifice
a duplicator for a duplicator?
No, give me the money
Okay, quick draw, refund Oh my god, wait Okay, I gotta get
the refund on this Give me it That's good, what is that?
What is that over here?
Is that just a see that?
There's like something here.
Oh, it's just a map.
Okay, never mind.
Don't mind me.
That's just a map.
Oh, my God.
I definitely need it.
I'm gonna grab that.
Oh, no.
All right.
All the map but it looked weird but i was like oh that's
just i thought that was an item but that's just me being
stupid all right we need zeros now we gotta aim for some
zeros this is not good
this oh it's just all ones it's just it's just all ones guys
all right green or or chat all right sorry they're both
green green or a mask epi they're both green okay uh oh
re-roll re-roll oh shit nice okay mana magic or arm greed or
more greed oh or greed yes greed or greed okay the greed is
confusing me there's that i can't remember which is the
right greed getting
lots and lots of oh my god i'm just it's just raining mana
now
okay i should kill a lot of them oh i feel like we need
knife though i feel like we just need more zeros to just at
least start the combo who needs to start the combo guys
oh my god it's just perfect okay bible wandered zeros do we
want more zeros fuck it let's just grab another zero in
there god why did it not give me another zero
okay we'll just kill it with the knife we'll just all right
the knife the knife comes in zero one two three That should
kill him.
Oh, but I'm always using the zeros, though.
Oh.
I don't think we need more ones.
That's the thing.
I think we're okay with the ones.
Oh, it's so shiny.
Oh, it's so shiny, though.
It is.
I re-roll.
No!
Why did I re-roll?
I lost my shiny.
I...
It was so shiny!
Why did I re-roll?
It was so beautiful.
Okay.
Alright, we'll reduce mana to zero.
Receive double mana instead.
Okay, but that's on a zero.
That sucks.
If I was on any other card, it would have been great.
I got a leader now.
It's on the knife, though.
Or armor strike on the knife.
We get armor strike on the knife?
Let's try it.
We'll try it.
We haven't tried this yet.
No, this game is fun.
Yeah.
Then we'll track.
Another axe.
And then Bible.
Oh my god.
We gotta grab that.
This guy is strong.
Okay, now we have a three combo too.
Which is good.
Alright.
Go in there.
Go have fun.
Yay!
Our little bird.
He's having so much fun killing things.
Alright, just put everything.
thing oh axe or garlic now i don't know if i'm i think we
have enough zeros now i don't know why i should do one or
two we need more ones or do we need more twos garlic or axe
i don't know we need more ones more twos all right more twos
because now it's just numbers
Duplicator axe.
Okay, yeah, and I'm glad I got an axe.
Vending machine.
Give me my money.
Zero.
One.
Oh, the double.
Why would I not do the double?
Oh, I ran out of ones.
Get duplicated and then grab magic.
Duplicator magic.
No future.
Uh, do we want more?
I don't think we need more threes.
I think we have two threes already.
More magic?
Alright, Tome.
Track this.
One.
This.
They're dead.
Alright, this has a candle next to them.
Sorry, I'm going to have to kill you because I need That
money.
Duplicator, axe.
Grab another card.
Magic.
There we go.
Oh my god.
What if we do another magic?
Magic.
Nice.
Just more magic.
Whoops, all magic.
There we go.
Oh, I wish it didn't reset.
Oh my god, imagine.
Just imagine how much magic we could have.
Yeah, no, this game is really fun.
The creators really know how to make addicting games.
Like, whoever the devs are, they are very smart.
I mean, vampire survivors and then straight to here.
My work is done.
They just know how to make good games.
They know how to make, like, good...
They used to make slot...
Okay, yeah, they...
The fact that they used to make slot machines?
Mior.
Yeah, they know how to...
How to work addiction correctly.
They know...
They know how addiction works.
They're too powerful.
Powerful.
All right, there we go.
Oh, shiny.
You're so shiny.
So shiny though.
So shiny.
Ooh.
Put on here.
It draws me in with the shiny.
Like, you know you want it, Doki.
The shine calls for you.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what am I gonna do with fucking more
magic?
Get more cards, too.
I lost count.
Oh, crown!
Okay.
Uh...
Bible.
Oh, I should have kept that.
I'm just going to use this now.
Draw another card.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh my gosh, there's so many cards.
Oh my god, I'm losing count.
There's too many cards on my screen.
That.
Draw another card.
And then Bible.
There's too many cards.
I'm like, my heart.
It's blurring all together.
There's way too many cards.
Okay, there.
He's dead.
Oh my god, we made it past him.
Teamwork, XP.
Oh, is that it?
Is death coming over now?
He's gotta stop me now.
I'm too strong.
Get that in here.
Level that axe up.
I got your weapon, death.
What you... Oh, wait.
That's not death.
Never mind.
Oh my god.
Okay, I mean, we do need the chicken now.
We don't need the chicken now.
I got too used to it.
Oh, for more mana.
Don't know what to get rid of, though.
I got rid of the armor.
I got you.
I got your weapon.
Got your weapon.
Okay, we need another zero.
Oh, I could have used that, no!
Grab this.
Grab that.
All right, send her in.
Oh no, okay.
Oh, why did I eat the chicken?
Why did I eat the chicken?
Draw two more cards, but then I could do this.
I'm going to draw two more cards.
And then candle.
Duplicator.
We got magic now.
Mana.
Babel.
Axe.
All right.
Nope.
Nice.
All right.
I think this is the last one in that area.
Candle.
Draw card.
It's magic.
Kill future.
Bible.
I'm cooking now.
I'm cooking.
Oh my god.
Magic.
Draw two cards.
Oh my god.
I could have done a duplicator.
Why did I do duplicator?
It's fine.
Another duplicator.
More duplicator.
magic they're spiral oh I think we need more twos but I
think we have enough ones we're missing ones and zeros okay
I mean we're missing zeros twos and threes now Sam we'll get
that just because we can I need zeros and twos
Statue card, axe, death spiral.
Oh, I didn't.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, he's dead.
Oh, it didn't count.
I forgot to count, guys.
I'll get more money.
I forgot to count.
Quick draw.
This is me I can play the card.
It got it.
Yeah, did you not count?
I want quick draw or return?
I was like, I should have enough stats.
1 minus 3 is still 3.
Alright, return or quick draw?
Oh, it keeps the combo bonus.
Return on the birds?
Alright, I'll do that.
Down I go.
Oops.
I knew the Bible I knew it I'm glad it's a Bible I was like
I don't know if it's worth it
950 I'm just I'm just gonna kill him right off the bat oh
the XP I wouldn't be greedy oh no no you need the zero don't
you can't keep getting XP bonus you're you're running out of
zeros it's all ones all your cards are just ones Doki yeah
keep doing this to yourself it's just so tempting guys you
don't understand
Like, oh my god, like they're just there, the crown.
You can't help it.
It's like staring at me, being like, pick me, dokey, pick
me, no you want to.
And you know you want to click me.
Oh, a four.
Oh my god, a four.
Because I know there was a two But guys, there's a four
Okay Zero
Three plus Okay, we got, let's get the four in there I was
like, what is Because four plus three equals three
Oh my god, another four.
Okay, we need twos, though.
We actually need twos.
We can't keep doing this.
Just by how much we want to.
Oh my god, guys.
But what if four...
Refund on that four?
That's some good-ass fours.
That's a lot of mana I could get back.
There you go.
We got the mega combo.
Got the double birds.
Oh my god.
Why does it keep giving me birds?
There's so many birds.
I can't keep track of them anymore.
The birds Oops all birds Okay Oh Medusa's here now Let's
join it Okay guys I think I have too much magic Do I want
magic Magic or magic Oops all magic Oh now I have no magic
Okay That's fine
Okay This is a little bad, though.
Oh, this is a little bad.
I used up all my zeros at the end there.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay, I'm going to grab the zero.
Well, I'm going to grab the zero because we really, really
need that right now.
Grab magic.
Draw another card.
No!
Oh my god, I
forgot!
I keep forgetting how to count, guys!
I don't know what's wrong with me.
My Oshikad count.
I keep forgetting.
I keep thinking three.
Three minus four is four.
Some shall fucking know.
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta get rid of some ones.
We gotta get rid of some light tomes.
We have too many.
Alright, nice.
Empty tomes too much.
Okay, there you go.
Someone gets rid of zeros.
I don't know what I'm doing.
feeling anymore.
There's like 20 cards in my hand.
I need to go back to counting
school.
Holy shit, what the fuck about it?
I could grab the duplicator.
I grab more, put more birds in there.
Just fuck it, all birds.
All right, bird.
and then axe and then burn wait why did it stop shooting
birds okay
there you go okay do we want more zeros or ones I don't know
anymore guys I there's so many cards in my hand what am I
gonna do it's not fitting in but it's like when in uno it's
like draw 20 And I don't know anymore.
I've drawn too many cards.
It's splash damage.
Alright, just stop.
No damage at all.
That's fine.
I don't think I did any damage there, but that's okay.
Alright, and then magic wand.
Oh, nice.
Could gain money.
I could get money.
I could get...
I'm getting money.
I'm doing it.
Oh, yes.
Yes!
Money!
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
That's the last boss anyway.
This is the last boss.
I can see her.
I see you over there.
I know you're the last one.
There we go.
I had to think a little bit there.
I was just like...
armor
I don't have like any attacks
oh my god I have so many I'm just gonna drop that in there I
have so much XP now
what the fuck are in my hand oh my god now I have no one
I guess I'm gonna grab a one
Alright, whip!
Whipper!
Okay.
Magic.
Attract.
This.
Death Spiral.
Oh, she's dead.
Easy.
Seven, I need more XP.
I won't be satisfied until I have a thousand!
That's the holy one.
That's the death site.
I already have either of these
I mean like this is the last one.
It doesn't matter.
Oh cash out Yeah, it doesn't matter.
It's literally the last there you go.
Hello death.
It's great seeing you again All right, oh my god, I'm so
addicted.
This game is so fun.
I'm sorry this game is actually so fun It's it's just like
vampire survivors the addiction.
Thank God.
I can't believe they got they left the casino to make video
games.
Honestly, they I feel like they'd make less money not doing
this like going like they make less money leaving the casino
and going into game development.
The fact that this this is not like this there's no gotcha
in there is impressive.
The guys like the devs like really like grew a or some shit.
The desert like, maybe I should stop being evil.
Alright, let's buy it.
Okay, let's buy a new character.
They went for the good ending.
Oh my god, I could be a priest.
Let's buy the priest.
It's time to confess your sins.
I grab that.
What's through one?
Okay, now I'm broke.
Never mind.
I can't buy anything else.
I'm just so addicted to XP.
I'm addicted to numbers going up.
It's too late.
I already spent it.
Can't buy luck.
I don't remember how expensive this game is, to be fair.
What did I get?
Increased mana every hundred cards.
Oh, I spent so many cards.
go up mine go down keep rolling keep rolling just keep
rolling oh my god there's the teeny bridge we gotta go to
the teeny tiny bridge i have christ on my side oh my god
it's just one way maybe i made a mistake or two callers
trigger two more abilities before leaving crawler
Oh, shit.
Okay, I have armor, though.
I forgot how to cast.
Oh, my God.
Maybe I'm too weak for this area.
I can't tell.
There's so many of them.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm going to reroll.
Oh, crown!
Crown!
I'll get Duplicator, too.
All right, now I have more Bibles.
They're so tanky.
They are.
All right, more Bible.
More Bibles!
Oh, my God.
And they keep on coming.
They don't stop.
It's okay.
Two more abilities before leaving.
What does this even mean?
I don't understand this.
Oh, the Bibles.
Like, what do you mean by crawlers trigger two more
abilities?
Like, like what kind of abilities?
Oh, isn't my character card?
Oh, your character was saved for two more.
Oh, I see.
Four more abilities before leaving.
Alright.
Deals 140 damage now.
How many of them are there?
It's like they're lining up!
They heard there was a concert!
Michael Jackson's back from the dead!
Earns coins when...
They're like...
They're lining up from the concert!
He's gonna do Thriller!
Michael Jackson's hologram is performing right now!
They gotta go!
Okay.
Michael, is that you?
Is this a mean and greet?
This might be actually, this could be a mean and greet right
now.
This is a never ending mean and greet.
They're just vibing menacingly.
Okay.
I can't see the end.
I don't think the end exists, guys.
I don't think it exists.
Alright.
Can we get...
I don't even know what to get.
I feel like more mat.
I feel like more zeros.
I've lost track.
I've...
I'm gonna add zeros.
I've lost track.
I couldn't tell.
Oh.
Oh my god, there's the end!
Oh my god, we made it!
We actually made it!
I didn't even think there would be an end!
I didn't even think that was possible!
We made it!
Oh my god, it's back!
They're back!
Like, you thought you saw the last of me?
I think I need more ones, actually.
Alright, here we go.
area all right we definitely need more ones now
oh all right how did he hit me
he's like never stopping from attacking okay we need more
ones all right we need more attacks actually we need two
more damage okay
add one more yeah i need more bibles so many of them want
They all want to hear.
They all want to buy a Bible.
I need more threes.
If I could find a three.
They all want to hear.
They're like, what did Jesus do on Sunday?
How many days did he come back?
Okay, nice.
What the fuck is that?
We have a whip now, which is good.
I don't even know we need a heart.
I don't even get to get a whip.
Bacha!
Quick, Toki.
Tell me about Easter.
They want to hear what happens on Easter.
Okay.
I'll grab armor right now.
Uh, candle.
Duplicator.
We'll grab more bibles and another bible.
The tornado weasels.
Oh, we are so fucked.
We need...
We can't be pushed back because there's a fucking line.
Okay.
Oh, I see the end.
Oh, thank God there's a two.
The candle.
Okay, we need more damage.
I'm going to grab the axe.
We need more, like, attack moves.
We can't keep praying.
Okay.
All right, oh my god, none of these do anything.
I mean, what can I do?
Everything is just, it's just a hog.
Do you want more mana?
Do you want more pray more?
It is just like, keep praying guys, keep praying.
What is that?
Unlocks.
Oh, I got the blacksmith.
Nice.
Hey, look, more mana.
Don't think about the... We're not here to do damage.
Yes, God wouldn't want that.
Yeah.
I got the blacksmith.
I don't know what the blacksmith does, but we got it.
Okay, oh, I should have done...
I fucked it up.
I fucked up that combo.
I'm gonna grab it long-term for the damage boost.
Oh, no.
This is not good.
This is not good at all I need more damage cards
Okay, I can't we can't keep doing mana.
We actually need more damage cards We need something to kill
them.
I just keep pulling magic
Okay Oh, no, this is not good.
The priest ain't doing so well right now.
Please!
Stop pulling the tomes!
Someone shuffle the cards!
Someone shuffle the fucking cards!
Someone, please!
Shuffle the cards!
He wasn't prepared.
fared for the fad medium.
God will provide surely.
I just need more shuffles.
Okay, do I- oh my god, I don't even know what to get.
Brace them.
Just keep praying.
Do we get Bracer?
Draw or magic wand?
Hand size, all right.
Okay.
Thank God I didn't.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay.
Grab that.
And run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The bridge is so hard.
It's actually so hard.
Okay, there's two more.
Two more stacks there.
All right.
I don't even get a lot of money out of this, too.
That's the worst part.
The duplicator.
The armor.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
I don't even know what to get.
I don't think I'm...
I'm not running out of mana.
That's for sure.
I'm not...
I think I have plenty of enough mana.
Okay, twos.
Yeah, you're right.
We need twos.
Oh my god, someone quick.
Get me some chicken.
Oh, I guess.
Okay.
I guess.
Don't fuck it.
Let's go.
We get an evil book now.
Is anyone gonna feed this poor priest?
This priest is so hungry.
He's so fucking hungry right now.
Okay.
Oh, no.
How hungry, please someone donate to the church.
I don't have a lot of HP left.
Oh.
It's the best I can do.
Mechanos.
I didn't think everybody was gonna show up during the
sermon.
oh no i don't know i don't know agreed surely nothing bad
will happen
oh no okay
armor bible act drop get a card more cards whip okay
on my screen.
Duplicate.
Axe.
Cans.
Okay, there you go.
They're all dead.
Oh, thank you for another book.
Keep attacking to earn coins.
Thank you.
That's, I'm, oh, thank God.
Okay, God.
God is real.
They actually thank God
Oh my god we have one Okay this better be worth Is this
worth it guys Do you think it's worth it Do you think it's
worth it I think we do need the armor though We don't have
any other blue cards That's the worst part Probably not I do
believe that we do need the armor.
Oh, if only we got that armor right now.
He's getting an armor.
Oh, there's the Holy Sword.
He's ready to kill me.
Oh, the Holy Sword.
He knows of my crimes.
Okay.
Oh, he's getting closer.
I didn't know.
The heart of the card, just keep on believing, Toki.
Keep on believing.
Oh, I should have got the...
I should have grabbed the...
Okay.
Okay, I'm going to do 540.
There we go.
More cards.
Okay.
I think he's very far from me now.
I have so much knockback.
Oh.
This better be the end of the bridge.
I swear to God, if I dig down a bridge, where am I going?
Like, where am I going?
You have to dig down a bridge.
Where could I possibly go?
Oh.
Oh, why is there eyes now under the bridge of course, Doki?
What?
What is going on?
Am I being counted on right now?
Why is it watching me?
Stop looking!
Stop watching!
Stop!
Why is it looking at me?
I don't like it!
Oh, okay, okay, overkill.
It's rude to say it.
Stop staring!
It's rude!
Oh, we is judging your sins.
Armor or...
He's streaming your build right now.
Yay!
Money!
Okay, I can evolve.
I have...
I feel like...
He's looking at my spirit just did.
Alright, here we go.
What do we get?
Every time that I spell the boss gets even you have cards.
Oh, that's what it does.
Gina, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, is that the end?
caching out.
I was going to say there's no way.
Goodbye.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I made it to the end of the bridge.
I was going to say there's no way.
Where the fuck am I going to go after the bridge?
Am I like, am I going to sort of fall down the bridge and
die?
Is that how it's going to get me?
Alright, we got Evolve King Bible.
Oh, we're making so much progress.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Go back to the end.
Oh, that's it.
Alright, Let's get Poe.
Let's grab him.
Get this old man.
I will do one more run.
Oh my god, I've been streaming for four hours.
This game is so addicting.
The bridge too.
Welcome the bridge too.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, I add more gems.
What do I even want to add it on?
I can't believe.
I can't add it on the holy sword though.
One more run.
I don't want to add it on, though.
On the empty ones?
The armors?
Oh, empty tome.
Yeah, I should add it on this.
Bam.
There you go.
I'll put it on the empty tome.
And then...
Oh my god, we gotta put it on this one.
No, I'm broke!
I don't have enough money.
That's fine.
We'll save up for it.
I'll save up.
I definitely would play this off stream 100% this is really
fun I have more stuff now gain 25% more coins I feel like
coins I feel like greed and one mana per rank I don't have
any money for any of these skip choices and get XP instead 2
per rank do I want that?
I don't think so
Yeah, but I don't have enough money for any of this.
I feel like on mobile, they would make so much money if they
put this on mobile.
Alright, how many?
Oh, dairy plant.
Okay.
Alright, old man.
I think you're ready for the dairy plant.
It's level four.
Oh my god.
We're gonna send this old man straight to hell.
Alright.
Oh god.
Okay, it's fine old man.
You got this.
I believe in you I still believe in you There we go This
place does not look friendly toky Grab the knife
Yeah All right garlic
Grab Poe in here I need to remember blue, I just draw one
card.
I need to remember that.
I keep forgetting the blue.
There we go.
Spell banner, add four armor.
Collars trigger two more abilities before leaving.
Oh, this is hard.
Wait, do you want...
Which one do we get, chat?
Which one do we get, dragons?
Blue does give me more card draw.
Binder?
Or armor?
Armor?
Okay.
Draw a card.
Oh, we have more armor, though.
Oh, we need more mana.
We actually need more mana, though.
Draw a card.
Come on, where's my card?
Oh, oh, Poe's not activated!
Fuck!
Okay, there we go.
Poe's activated now.
Okay.
There we go.
We need...
We need some mana stuff.
Okay, this guy, I feel like...
He's gonna fucking collapse soon.
Are there any upgrades?
Okay.
I don't.
I need more bracers or some shit.
Like, what the fuck do I need?
Okay, we got the cart.
Okay.
And...
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, I should have grabbed the armor!
Oh god, I need all the luck I can get.
I need some tomes!
He's so broke!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, we're looking rough.
He ain't doing so well.
He needs some mana for sure.
We need some tomes.
Okay.
Okay, that should...
How much does that do?
Okay, that actually saves me.
A knife.
Armor.
Garlic.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, Poe.
Armor.
Candle.
There we go.
Armor.
Knife.
There we go.
Nice.
Garlic.
Stone mask.
He doesn't get any money.
I've only found one dollar.
Wait, it's poop forever, bro.
More re-roll.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Maybe one more re-roll?
No, okay.
No more re-roll.
Who took this guy out of retirement?
out I don't even know what to get wait I don't think Bible
or knife or golden armor Bible or armor I'll do armor then I
need another brace for Poe oh adds armor let's go I wonder
if it gives me like, oh wait, do I do double damage or
return?
Wait, which would be better?
Armor on my knife?
Or garlic?
A knife or garlic, guys.
Or double damage.
What would be best?
Return on- no, we're not returning on.
Maybe garlic?
Garlic armor?
Okay.
Put that on.
Okay, at least we got...
Thank God.
Oh, no, that's the boss.
Whoops.
Alright, we go straight in.
Oh, I should...
No, we got good.
Poe.
Okay, more armor.
Oh, I should went candle first before I do damage.
Okay.
So you can't hurt me.
Poe.
Armor.
knife garlic armor candle or they can't hurt me that's good
knife candle oh I should take it why do I always take candle
last I don't know what's wrong with me
oh a fucking corset gives me two garlics now
okay at least the damage is going up, though.
Oh, fuck!
Whoops.
That's fine.
Poe.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Finally light to him.
Thank God.
We needed that.
Oh.
Finally some mana.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Okay, we're doing enough damage and we have enough
protection now.
Oh.
It just takes so long to kill them.
He's so weak.
He must be, like, good for long game, late game, right?
Because he's so weak right now.
Late game, right?
Is he good for late game?
Just all gold armor.
Just all armor.
Oh my god, why is he not dead yet?
Why is he not dead?
Is he supposed to be a multiplayer character?
Like, what's going on?
How is he still alive?
This is only level one.
All right, here we go.
He's never gonna touch.
Oh, he touched me.
12 hours stream of just this one guy.
I'm doing like baby death.
damage right now.
Oh my god, no.
No, he can't do the eyes on me right now.
No, you can't do this to me.
Okay, there we go.
Can't touch me.
There we go.
Oh my god.
It's happening too fast.
I'm just pressing every button.
Just keep drawing cards.
I have the poe.
Just draw cards!
Who cares anymore?
I'm just pressing buttons.
I do 20!
Excuse me, how much damage do I do?
I only do like 40 damage per shot.
Okay.
This is the most intense fight of them all.
there's no way there's no way there's more to this there's
no this guy has to be end game there is no way i can i'm not
digging another tunnel i'm not digging another tunnel to
wherever it's leading me oh
no i don't have a lot of armor here
all right more leg tomes please i'm just level five one's
gonna show up a second a second boss that's showing up at
the dairy market
yeah I'm at six hundred and five how high can I fucking go
the bosses are just lining up and chat is like about robots
like where is she
Alright.
I have a light comb.
I don't know what to do with this one.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh my god he actually hurt me this time.
He's actually, he's finally made it.
He's, he got through the armor for once.
Okay, another arm.
He's slowly weighing me down.
It really is.
Slow and steady.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
I'll take $17, honestly.
Thank god.
There we go.
Give me that $34.
$400.
Oh my god, I got him.
I fucking got him.
It's finally over.
I have to go down.
There's more to this.
Oh no.
What do you mean there's more?
It's just a light.
Oh, there's more.
I thought it was the end.
I legitimately thought I made it out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Look at the damage I do.
I should might need that.
I actually might need that.
Guys, I don't think...
pose it.
Po might not be the chosen one.
I have a feeling.
Po might not be it.
Po absolutely is not the it.
Okay.
Po kiss the tank, but that's why you hate it.
With all my might.
He's The Poe Experience.
He truly is the Poe Experience.
Okay.
At least I can have armor here.
Oh my god, when will I level up?
When will I level up?
Please, give me more crowns!
Okay, I don't even know.
I don't even know.
What do I even do?
What build can you even do with Poe?
Oh.
Bible.
Took you to kill things.
Guys, I'm trying so hard to kill things.
I'm not I'm not Trust me I trust me guys I've tried to do my
best to kill anything
Okay Oh now it doesn't Fucking give me shit
Alright I'm just gonna kill this Garlic time
Gotta go to the old man build.
Alright, he's dead.
He's finally dead.
When can I level up?
Okay, at least we get more cards.
Oh, I...
Ugh, fuck it.
Oh, I forgot to grab armor.
I forgot to grab armor.
I didn't think I needed for some reason.
Oh, I forgot to get magic.
Poe always fucks me up.
Doesn't need armor.
I just need the armor.
Okay.
You're not resting here, Poe.
You're going back in it.
You're not allowed to rest, Poe.
We need a crown.
Oh, I don't need luck.
I need a crown right now.
okay I should be fine yeah I tank all those
okay it's a lot of projectiles which is good
the garlic the knife all right what do we get I don't even
know guys I don't even know what to do with Poe do we get
more magic blame me oh that that's we should have kept them
in the home guys we Should have kept him in that hole.
Why did we take him out of retirement?
I don't even know if he knows where we are.
I'm pretty sure he doesn't even know where we are right now.
Okay.
He's gonna grab it.
Pose here.
Destroy Annius.
Just draw one card temporarily.
Okay.
I don't even know.
This will disappear.
Okay, fuck it.
Good luck, youngster.
Alright.
Oh.
Knife, rune, or golden arm?
I've...
Knife or rune?
We're not doing more armor.
We're fine.
We don't need more
Right now I'm trying to figure out how to survive
What what Think about tanky you could be I want to kill
stuff first.
Guys.
What we're lacking are kills right now.
Oh my
god, we should have enough armor for that.
Oh my god.
How is he here?
You're not even the main boss.
Okay.
One thing for hours.
Oh my god, please.
Please!
Draw a card, draw a card!
Alright, there you go.
Wish I had enough for your armor.
What?
Most mad costs are randomized temporarily?
My armor!
all right okay we're back and then we lost all of it all
right it's fine we just use everything it's fine and then
have a knife just for fun
okay pose back oh my god i forgot oh i didn't get the light
dome oh no okay for three minus three that's fine that's
fine everything's Why?
The Koonimini pot.
Uh, draw card.
Oh, why didn't I get the light tone?
Why did I get- Oh, now I'm confused!
Oh, Poe, why are you so expensive?
Okay, that means more mana for me.
Uh, candle, garlic.
Attract...
Uh...
Magic...
There we go.
More armor.
It's been four hours.
I feel like it's... I've been stuck here the longest in
those four hours, too.
Oh my god, I didn't want to do that.
It doesn't even matter what I press.
It doesn't fucking matter.
I just press everything I just press everything I'm
gonna poke it over here poke it in here oh please draw two
cards and then more magic and then garlic and then armor
Bible how much HP does he have just oh my god just get me
out of here Just at least
Oh my god, how do you confuse me right now?
Yes, it's been 3,000 years
I'm just, I was just pressing buttons right now In Tokyo, we
love you But we got some places to be You think I want to be
here?
Just pressing Just sucking Oh hell
I wish I know how much HP he has I wish I was given
I wish I was just given an idea given hope oh my it doesn't
even matter it doesn't matter what I press
oh my god 72 that's the biggest number I've never seen that
high I've never seen a number to go that high before I
actually have never seen it.
That's crazy.
Okay, two tanks are fighting right now.
It's Ryan versus Ryan on King's Road.
They both have five supports healing him.
We don't know who's going to win yet.
It might be a while.
And he's second now.
Oh my god, how did he hit me?
don't understand oh my god it's over it's like it's over i
don't think i need more fat it's over guys it's not even the
plot in the hour have you ever considered getting more mana
and supports fell asleep then one of the supports DCs guys
one of them I am the better tank we're free we're not it'll
make me him die and give him dying sets him free more but
why are you like this so I think in the end, I think he's
one.
Guys, I think he's one.
He gets to leave.
Metapod versus Metapod.
What do we even do?
It should have been me.
Not him.
We hardened too hard that he shattered.
luck
where luck or mana we'll go with luck oh my god we actually
have other stuff we can upgrade all right grab an axe
there we go but wait is that arm oh my god what can I
upgrade Oh my god, can I do a holy wand?
Wait, this might actually work out for me, guys.
We can have at least, we can have a holy wand.
I'm gonna grab the holy wand.
The holy wand can at least do something.
Is that damage I see?
Oh my god.
I didn't think it'd be possible.
oh my god we don't even have enough mana for the holy one
because it's one tome we didn't even have enough mana for
the holy one truly we're suffering we're here to just suffer
oh my god why will we not have it i'm i'm just running this
I don't care.
I think this is over.
Oh my god, that is mad.
Okay, we could have mana right now and then we could
actually, oh my god.
Oh my god.
What is this character?
What is he?
What are you, Poe?
What the fuck are you?
I'm just grabbing this
Okay I need to check on I don't know why he bought me
Alright Okay Back to Poe Back to the longest fight of my
life Someone please Someone please Let me out of here Slow
and steady And he wins the race, Duke.
Yes, they always say.
It's never.
One game, she says, and she decides to play Poe.
I didn't know.
I didn't know what lies in store for me.
All right.
I'm just going to grab that.
Fuck it.
Oh my god, Poe, he's back.
Okay, I'll take those.
I take those.
Alright.
This is the most damage I've ever seen him make.
Let's hope he can continue to do well.
I've never seen so much damage before from Poe.
Oh god, we match me duplicate it.
Oh my god, there he is!
There he is!
There's the boss!
I don't even...
I don't know what you want from me, bro.
What do you want from me?
What the fuck do I do with this?
Oh I forgot to grab armor.
Oh fuck, okay.
I'm just gonna go for that.
I don't even trust grabbing another card right now.
Okay.
We have to do what we can get.
Now grab the armor.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We might be free.
We might...
In the end, think about it, guys.
Think about it.
I
can I can feel freedom There might There might be freedom
Okay Grab the duplicator and then grab garlic in this Maybe
just one more run Guys I can't I'm not strong enough I'm not
strong enough To deal with foe Oh no not again Not the
fucking eyes!
My god, not the eyes!
Only have five armor, so I hope...
Oh, thank god!
Oh no!
I don't even know what to get!
I need more tomes Who do I even get?
Oh, finally Oh my god, okay fraser or tome guys fraser or
tome.
I I do need more tomes.
I do need more tome Oh my god, is it oh a poking back
Oh, just so, okay.
Do we evolve or the mana rebate?
I feel like we could die on Axe.
Just three more just dash out.
Evolve?
Evolve, Axe or Tracer?
80 years has passed.
Doki is still on Poe.
Doki is still.
She's still on Poe.
She has not left.
Because I'm ordering food.
I didn't think Poe would take me.
So long.
Give me a sec.
Let me get my food.
It was something that...
No, the place closed.
No.
I thought I'd be done with Poe earlier.
What time did it close?
Don't tell me it closed.
Oh my, it closed 10 minutes ago.
I thought I'd be finished with Poe.
I really did.
Poe has never, Poe did this to me.
Poe!
oh my god I really wanted to eat that particular place too I
was really craving for it oh po oh just one last run I do
the choice bomb the run po I knew I was debating it I was
like should I order food before I do this last run.
Nah, it's gonna be quick.
Nah, the run will be alright.
It's not gonna take me that long.
I'm always holding us hostage and I don't know what to do.
No, that was actually the only place I wanted to eat today.
I had the cravings.
No!
I'm so sad pastoki strikes again I'm so sad I really wanted
to eat that particular place too all right I'm just going to
get the giant nigiri again I guess she'll start I'm getting
a giant nigiri wait unless they have the other place I sort
of wanted to go wanted to eat there's this other place with
kimpop.
I was like debating about getting that kimpop.
Guys, guess what?
That place is all so close.
No!
Poe!
Why did you do this to me?
I got poed.
Everything is close.
Never again.
Nice.
I got poed!
Why were they all closed?
Oh, I could get art, um, the army soup.
Was it called?
The army hot pot.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
I got poed, yes.
I got fucking code where is it where the fuck okay there you
go the army based style hot pot no I just want kid pop I
just want kid pop I don't want this right now oh yeah i'm
gonna grab i'm gonna grab the giant ass nigiri fuck this
when i order my big ass nigiri i'm so sad i can't believe it
i can't believe it's close
all right i got poed i got poed oh great Oh, reliable chumbo
nigiri.
How much mana do I have?
None?
Alright, let's go.
Kill one row.
Do I don't want to use that?
What the fuck is?
Okay, whatever.
Just kill them.
I'd be with you.
I don't care.
it's a waste just get them out of here oops
i should grab the armor oh my gosh i'm one step closer to
death oh don't don't prevent me from a good time oh my god
honestly i'm gonna take the crown i'm gonna maybe this will
help in some way all right don't tempt me with a good time
guys no armor oh i'm so close i'm almost there
oh you're so close
oh my god i don't even have oh wait i have seven okay there
we go
what do i get luck no no give me my money give me my money
Like, why do you have two mana?
Like, what am I gonna do with you?
Good luck, youngster.
Oh my god, that doesn't even matter.
Oh my god, you're still alive.
Oh my god, now the Minotaurs are here.
All right.
All right, Poe, welcome back.
oh what's in here what's in here oh thank god in slippery
press all i'm oh thank god at least we found the relic you
know i'm good after all that at least we found the relic
okay
oh freedom oh but dad think of it don't you think of it this
way but at this time you finished They'll be open again.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat thing.
Oh my gosh.
Freedom.
The curse has been lifted.
Get this old.
Put this man back into his retirement old.
Add three amount.
Add one amount when a...
Oh my god, I don't even fucking...
Let's just...
You should have seen me in my youth.
From grandpa to dead man.
Dead grandma.
Surely it's not as bad.
Surely dead grandma is not as bad as Poe.
To grandpa to sleep.
Put him back in the retirement home.
All right, let me second.
I think I have enough, right?
Was a thousand.
Oh, it's almost 1,500.
I want to put...
Oh, it's two...
I had to save for that.
All right, guys.
gonna call it here or we do one more round and run until my
food's here no i should call it here i we're free anyway
guys i'm gonna call it here guys we're freed we're free from
foe but it was supposed to be a one quick run and then we we
were trapped in the in the poeverse for eternity it felt
like past playing this character like we were trapped in
post world anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check yep move around get that blood flowing if you
stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys bye